hi sorry about that welcome to this
virtual meeting of the council before we
begin today's business i feel it only
right that we take a moment to reflect
on the impact of the coronavirus
pandemic across our district
our lives have changed immeasurably over
the recent months and our thoughts and
sympathies are with those who've lost
family and friends during this time
i would ask members officers and those
watching our livestream to join me in a
one-minute silence to remember those we
have lost during this period and we will
also remember in this time our
ex-colleague terence curran who served
our council from 2011 to 2015. in that
time terrence represented the stonehams
as ward councillor and sat on many
committees including planning control
and scrutiny our thoughts are with his
family at this very difficult time
thank you my first remind um as all of
um some domestic arrangements
please make sure that microphones are
muted when you're not speaking
thank that you do not interrupt other
speakers please our members are reminded
not to use the messaging chat function
during the meeting unless it's unless it
is to report a pecuniary non-pecuniary
interest or to notify the chair that you
wish to make a proposal or to leave the
chamber
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting that you may be asked to leave
additionally if you would like to speak
please can you use the race hand on
teams and then you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair but
please await your turn
if members lose connection to the
meeting that they must contact the
member support officer mandy smith asap
and as this is a virtual meeting you
need not stand to address the chair
i would like to remind everyone that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you if you make a representation to
the meeting you have deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you're
also consented to being filmed by the
council as the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film or photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded can
i move to the agenda please
agenda item number one apologies for
absence
non-received chair
[Music]
i i now ask the corporate manager for
governance and civic office to take a
roll call
okay councillors please can you reply
present when i call out your name
counselor morrison
[Music]
but i can see you so that's fine cancer
field
present councillor flatman
present councillor fleming
person cancer geek
present councillor gould
present that's a guthrie
present councillor hattingham present
councillor hicks present council pump
freeze
i can see cancer humphries that's fine
councillor mansell
present councillor madison
i can see you as well councillor mellon
[Music]
yeah i can see you
present how to pass more
present dr phillips
president council pratt
present
richardson present
present that's the stringer
present
the turner
presents
cancer
present that's the
[Music]
agenda item number two declaration of
interest by councillors
we've already noted the following local
non-pecuniary interests for councillors
appointed to the council's companies
that's councillor rick mayer who's the
director of sifko capital limited
councillors brewster eppingham gould and
maya who are um mid-suffolk
suffolk holdings limited is there any
further declarations of interest
okay cool item number three um mc-1944
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 27th of february 2020 for
accuracy only are there any issues with
accuracy
councilor mansell
councillor mounts at mansell
it's being slow sorry it was unmuted and
then it muted again um i didn't send you
email earlier in the week um about the
minutes
um i can't i need to just find the email
to remember what page numbers they were
sorry
um
uh right on page 19
i had a supplementary question uh which
referred to the joint local plan it's
listed in the minutes as the
neighborhood plan
okay was that the only one well the
other things were a couple of typos
which hopefully got picked up
yes um thank you thank you councillor we
will make sure that those are put into
the amended minutes
thank you
council field do you have something
extra to add
yes just a couple of fairly minor points
on page 22 paragraph 92 14.
uh i it says
the council should replace
the housing stock through the right to
buy a scheme i think you should say the
stock sold through the right to buy
scheme
and the sentence below that it says
ensure that modern standardized houses
were built
i think the intention was it should be
modern standard houses
it shouldn't be all the same
then on page 30
um there's a
thing that talks about um
it's the paragraph about above 93-13 so
it must be 93-12
sorry i can't see it on mung.gov it's um
it says
uh council put up rents by cpi plus one
percent
and
it should say
it
and had assured councillors that clients
would receive it's the council doing the
assuring not the government
so
you want me to repeat that or are you
happy
that's fine that's fine cancer we will
note those amendments in the minutes
thank you
so could i have a proposal for those
minutes uh thank you madam chairman i'm
happy to propose
thank you could i have a seconder
i'm happy to second thank you very much
i will now ask the corporate manager for
governance and civic office to take a
roll call vote
thank you chair
members please can you apply for against
or abstain councillor morrison
[Music]
councillor brewster
humphreys
cats and morley
four that's the muller four
norris
four
otton
four to phillips
four cancer pratt
four that's a richardson four that's the
scarf or how's the stringer four
turner
four that's the wall boys four
it's a willem
i didn't get asked but i am four yes
sorry i do apologize and counselor
madison you were four as well i did lip
read what you said i think you were on
meat at the time thank you
okay
okay the minutes of the meeting will
have been confirmed i'll be signed at
the next practical opportunity
agenda item number four mcslash 19-45
the chairman's announcements i refer you
to that paper to be noted
item number five leaders announcements i
would like to invite councillor morley
to present her update
thank you chair
i would like to begin today by taking a
moment to reflect on the effect that the
coronavirus pandemic has had on our
lives and on our district
our world has changed dramatically in
the course of just a few months and we
have had to adapt quickly in order to
support our residents and communities
the virus has affected us all leaving an
indelible gap for those who have lost
friends and family
our thoughts and sympathies are with
everyone who has lost lost loved ones
during this time
i doubt that any of us could have
accurately predicted the events of
recent months or the role that we would
come to play and continue to play in
supporting our residents communities and
businesses through lockdown and beyond
i would like to take a moment to thank
my fellow councillors
who regardless of political persuasion
have united to support our towns
parishes and communities through this
crisis
i would also like to pay tribute to our
council officers working long hours on
the front line or behind the scenes to
support those most in need and to keep
our services running for residents
and i would like to recognize the
resilience of our amazing communities
whose rallying efforts have truly
demonstrated why mid-suffolk is a place
i am proud to call home
together we have protected the most
vulnerable members of our communities
together we have supported our business
and economy
and together we have kept essential
services running safely throughout
the ways in which we have supported the
district are too varied to list him for
but to give just a few headlines
our council has provided community
groups across mid-suffolk with more than
91 000 pounds in financial support
in order to help them to help others
including over 16 000 pounds for the
district's food banks
the home but not alone helpline manned
by redeployed council officers to
provide seven day a week support through
the height of the crisis
has taken almost a thousand calls from
people in need of food medical supplies
or advice
to date we have helped more than 1700
businesses across mid-suffolk access
more than 19 million
19 million pounds in funding through the
small business rates relief grant
retail hospitality and leisure grant and
discretionary grants
and we continue to work with partners
across our districts to get our high
streets reopened and trading safely
emergency temporary accommodation has
been found for all rough sleepers or
those at risk of homelessness with
support in place to avoid them returning
to the streets in future
meanwhile our waste teams have kept
household and recycling collections
going for the duration
despite increased demand during lockdown
although temporarily suspended garden
waste collections are now back up and
running as well
essential repairs and safety checks in
our council houses have continued
keeping our tenants safe
our public realm has continued to ensure
our facilities are maintained and safe
to use in line with government
guidelines
and
our environmental health enforcement
building control and emergency planning
teams continue to keep our residents
safe
all of this has been achieved at pace by
officers who have found themselves
redeployed into new roles or working
remotely from their kitchen tables
whilst homeschooling their children and
juggling the same fears and challenges
as those they have been working
tirelessly to help
council meeting itself is of course
another example of how we have all had
to get used to new ways of working
with virtual meetings held publicly via
live streams
to ensure democrat democracy continues
to be open and transparent
i'm sure that during our emergency
response there will have been things
that could have been done differently
there was no tried and tested solution
that we could simply take off the shelf
and we needed to work quickly to meet
unprecedented requirements
but i defy anyone to say that our
councillors and officers have not given
their all to support our communities
when they needed us most
as we now transition from the response
phase to recovery our challenge is to
build on the lessons we have learnt from
this experience and to continue to work
together to find ways to help
mid-suffolk safely recover and emerge
from this crisis stronger and more
resilient than ever
thank you
agenda item number six
to receive notifications of petitions in
accordance with council
non-received chair
we're just having a problem with the
screen that will come back in a minute
the chair has just lost his screen so
a few seconds
i haven't got the right background
hang on one second bear with
mistake
right so we're back we're back where are
we set number six will be on is that
what we're on
sorry number seven
right
can people hear me
[Music]
right number gender item number seven
questions by the public in accordance
with the council procedure rules
none received chair
item number eight questions by
councillors in accordance with council
procedure rules
non-received chair
number nine
mc-19-46 overview and scrutiny committee
annual report i would like to invite
councillor willam to introduce his
report
thank you chair
i'm pleased to present my annual report
as chair of mid-suffolk overview and
scrutiny committee this can be found on
pages 43 to 71 of the agenda papers
our 2020
2021 work plan
was
i
sorry i'll start again
our nine our 2019 2020 work plan was
made up of a varied range of topics to
scrutinize but our work was disrupted
first by the general election and just
as we were getting back into a routine
by the covid19 viral pandemic
from mid-march all meetings were
cancelled until suitable arrangements
for virtual meetings could be made
most of the meetings during the year
have been joint meetings with baby
overview and scrutiny committee
alastair mccraw chair of labor overview
and scrutiny committee and i
have altered alternated chairing the
meetings
our agendas have included pre-scrutiny
of items prior to cabinet or council
decisions
scrutiny of topics selected by the
committee or requested by council
presentation
of important matters by senior officers
and witnesses from outside the two
authorities
and information bulletins requested by
the committee
the joint committee set up a task and
finished group to work with members and
officers from other suffolk authorities
to scrutinize the work of citizens
advice
and provide recommendations to the
scrutiny committees of the authorities
taking part
the work was particularly helpful in
providing a better understanding of the
breadth of work covered by citizens
advice
as well as the pressures they are under
and how they are funded
throughout the year the committee has
acted as a critical friend to officers
by working with them to investigate
improvements to service delivery
we have also continued to add value to
the council's decision-making process
i would like to thank henriette holloway
senior government support officer
committee services and jan robinson
corporate manager democratic services
for their input and support throughout
the year
also keith scarf who has been committee
vice chair throughout the year
i'm grateful to members of the committee
for their commitment
and to offices for providing clear and
concise responses to requests for
information
and excellent reports to the committee
thanks to to alice democrat chair of
baber overview and scrutiny is vice
chair adrian osborne and members of that
committee for working collaboratively
with the mid-suffolk committee
we have produced a draft work plan for
2020-21
which is included in the annual report
however i'm confident that monthly
meetings from now through to april 2021
will enable scrutiny of topics delayed
from spring 2020
to be completed
other issues will be incorporated into
the work plan and this will be presented
to council in september
i'd like to move the recommendation but
amend the date
so i propose that the mid-suffolk
overview and scrutiny committee's annual
report for
2019-20 be noted and i look for a
seconder
do we have a
do we have a seconder
chair i would like to second if i may
thank you very much i see we have a
couple of questions for you councillor
willem and we'll start with councillor
otton
council otto i think you're muted
so i am very beg your pardon
um yeah it's an excellent report um i
just would like to refer to your page 59
um and i realize obviously
that this report was obviously done way
in advance of the um pandemic
on the issue about universal credit
um obviously you've resolved in this
report that no further information
relating to universal credit or rent
arrears
but i think you will agree with me
that as a result of the corona virus
there are going to be numerous numbers
of people that are going to be
needing to apply for universal credit
and may well be
in having a problem with their rent to
risk so i'm just asking chairman that
you
will look at that in the future thank
yes certainly i'm happy to commit to
that
councillor ebern
um thank you very much chair um thank
you for that report councillor well um
um
i wanted to ask a question with regard
to the citizens advice bureau
um unfortunately i couldn't come to that
particular committee and i noted that
you had um recommended that cab was
received funding for a three-year period
which i understand it has
but i've also understood that the cab
had wanted to to get an increase on its
funding from mid-suffolk and i just
wondered whether that was covered and
whether that was something that
um
had
been asked of officers um at the council
thank you chair
uh certainly the um this this was mooted
with the cabinet member
um and
it was left in her hands
uh i i think that i think that the the
view of the cabinet member was that it
would be looked at on a year by year
basis
are there any other questions for
councillor wellam
okay thanks so much councilwoman do you
have anything else to add
no thank you very much
so thank you that report was for noting
only moving on to agenda item number 10
mc19
47 decisions taken by the chief
executive during the covert 19 pandemic
lockdown period under delegated powers
in accordance with part two of the
constitution i would like to invite the
monitoring officer to introduce the
report which is which is for noting
thank you chair i would like to present
the schedule of decisions taken by the
chief executive under his delegation to
act out of meeting
the decisions were predominantly taken
in april during the first few weeks of
the covert 19 lockdown to assist with
the council's emergency response to the
pandemic thank you
thank you very much
item number 11 mc19 48 special urgent
key decisions exempt from calling taken
by the cabinet member for economic
growth during the covert 19 pandemic
lockdown period under delegated powers
in accordance with part one of the
constitution
i would like to invite councillor morty
to introduce the report which is for
noting
thank you chair
i would like to report to the council
that on the 20th of may 2020 i granted
delegated authority to the cabinet
member for economic growth to agree the
discretionary business grants policy
using the powers given to me as leader
of the council by article 6 of the
constitution
the delegation was given on the grounds
of urgency as the council was required
to quickly agree a discretionary grant
scheme
and award those grants rapidly to
support local businesses through the
kovic 19 pandemic
i'm pleased to report to the council
that we have assisted fifty businesses
with over two hundred and forty thousand
pounds worth of funding since this
since this scheme was agreed
thank you chair
thank you
agenda item number 12 to report back on
council motion on climate change i would
like to invite councillor fleming to
update members on the actions taken by
the cabinet regarding the climate change
motion agreed at council on the 25th of
july 2019. this item is for noting only
thank you very much um chairman um
members and sorry
sorry i
noticed i'm sorry about that sorry um
counselor eben i've just i've just seen
is there something you'd like to say to
counselor morley thank you chair now i
just had a question on the on the item
um 11 um because in the um report it
refers to part three and also part one
and so
i wasn't quite clear in the constitution
that starts off referring to one part
and then the recommendation
refers to a second part so i just
wondered if the monitor monitoring
officer could clarify actually which
part it is thank you chair
emily are you able to assist
sorry councillors there was a slight
delay there with uh my unmuting um yes i
can can assist um chair uh section one
well actually part one of the
constitution the articles it talks about
the uh cabinet arrangements and that's
where the delegation
uh that the leader is able to give to
other cabinet members is held so that's
where part one comes in um
to the to the decision making and then
part three is the general scheme of
delegations
which talks about acting out of meetings
so both of those parts of the
constitution have to be read together to
get the complete delegation to a single
cabinet member
it does make sense
when you're working with the
constitution all the time even though it
sounds rather long-winded thank you
thank you emily thank you
so item number 12 to report back on
council motion on climate change i would
like to invite councillor fleming to
update members on the actions taken by
cabinet regarding the climate change
motion agreed at council on 25th july
2019 this item is for noting only
councillor fleming well thank you thank
you again very much chairman
members and members of the public
on behalf of our cabinet i'm delighted
to report to this council on actions
taken by cabinet regarding the climate
change motion that was agreed
uh on the 25th of july 2019.
on the 11th of july this year cabinet
unanimously approved a carbon reduction
management plan
which is the product of nine months of
work by a joint cross-party climate
change task force
supported very ably by our mids african
baby council officers
the cabinet decision took place at a
simultaneous meeting of both baber and
mid-suffolk cabinets at which both
approved the same management plan
and we intend to work closely with baber
as well as other local authorities in
suffolk to take this forward
this plan is not an end goal in itself
it is the beginning of a path to a
better decision-making and governance
process which will raise the profile and
importance of the environment
and our place within it
this is i believe what most people
in this in this district want
and it's what most people in suffolk and
the nation want as well
the management plan
can be viewed through a link in the
council agenda and i urge anyone
counselors public alike who may be
listening to this meeting
to have a look at it
the cabinet's focus will now move to
acting upon the initiatives within this
plan
and i look forward to the continued
involvement and support with the task
force members and all elected
councillors as we about embark upon this
work together
finally on behalf of task force members
i would like to thank our officers and
all those who have supported the group
particularly i would like to mention
cassandra clements for all the hard work
and forbearance that she has put into
this project
that is
what i would like to say about it that
is
my statement so thank you
have we all frozen or what's
what's happening
um chair uh the chair is having trouble
to unmuting herself so she'll be with
you in a few seconds okay
hang on
right and we
okay thanks sorry about that gang um
right thank you councillor fleming and
we'll move to item number 13 mcslash
1949 the local development scheme update
i would like to invite councillor byrne
to introduce this paper and to move to
the recommendation in the report
could i have a
a seconder
sorry no that's wrong we'll wait for
cancer burn
you want me to go now
um
yes thank you very much madam chair
the
local dream which i'm going to refer to
as the lds for the rest of this
introduction
is a document that councils are legally
required to prepare and maintain and
which shows the local planning
authority's work program for the
preparation
of development plan documents
what is before you today is a joint
local development scheme for both baber
and mid-suffolk district
councils
which sets out the proposed timetable
for the joint local plan
which i will refer to as the jlp from
now on
and the review of the community
infrastructure levy charging
schedules
as you know we published the new jlp
preferred options for consultation last
summer
and the responses have been collated
analyzed and considered
by the member working group
we are now in a period where further
work is being done
as outlined in paragraph 1.4
to take us to the next stage and
submission
whilst the lds identifies a broad time
scale by season
you will see a paragraph 4.2 of the
council report
that council meetings
are proposed for november 2020
followed by a statutory minimum six-week
public consultation
before submission of the joint local
plan to the secretary of state in winter
for an examination in public
these are statutory periods in the
production of the new jlp which cannot
be shortened
but i and my colleagues on the joint
plan program board
have done everything we can to ensure
the new local plan
will be delivered as soon as possible
including encouraging officers to draw
on extra resource when necessary
the lds timetable is tight but
achievable subject to the necessary
caveat in paragraph 1.5
i recommend therefore that this lds is
agreed and brought into effect from the
31st of july 2020
and i'll look for a second
thank you
happy to second
thank you very much councillor guthrie
can i just ask members that if you're
not speaking that you turn your cameras
off along with your microphone and then
when you do speak to put both your
camera and your microphone on
we will now move to questions and debate
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion and they
must be a question when we get to the
debate element counsellors will only be
allowed to speak once for three minutes
and this will be timed
who would like to start i see rachel
ebon's got a hand up
thank you very much chair um i've got um
two questions if i may um one is with
regards to
the
numbers within oh sorry within this this
whole timing
do we have enough time um in place
firstly if the housing
delivery numbers change which doubtless
they have done over the period of covid
and if population numbers change and
secondly we've got some new strategies
coming
into play which includes climate change
ones and
health and well-being so do we have
enough time within this time table to
incorporate those thank you very much
chair
um
thank you council eben
there are various unknowns as you will
have seen in in
paragraph 1.5
that
we have to assume
will not add
to the timetable that we have
projected
um
some of these things are quite out of
our hands
the government's revisions
of the uh the planning process
um the
uh the housing numbers etc etc if they
choose to make changes to that extent
uh to any marked extent they may well
add time to uh how we can deal with them
they may not we're well poised to to
handle
um most of the things or many of the
things that i think we're going to have
to anticipate
other than that i don't know whether i
can give you any further reassurances
i don't know whether any of my
colleagues i think we have one or two
officers attending but
unless you're
particularly unhappy with that response
i won't bother them at this stage
thank you
councillor stringer you have a question
yes i do chair uh thank you thank you
chair uh yes i just uh
i've almost lost count actually the
amount of documents i've seen like this
that put forward yet another timetable i
remember asking councillor y brow
three years ago
if not longer what the timetable was and
he guaranteed me that by 2020 we would
have a joint local plan
done and dusted
and
i've now seen yet another timetable
suggesting it's not going to be until
2022 when this thing gets finished so i
i thought we were using lockdown as an
opportunity to actually speed this
process up because i i certainly was one
that attended hours and hours of
meetings early in lockdown where i
thought we'd thrashed an awful lot of
this out so i i would actually quite
like an explanation as to why we now see
a longer timetable than we had four
months ago
um
thank you councillor swinger the
timetable we had four months ago
um at that time was out of date uh
this is the update to that
to that timetable
um
councillor weibrow's
promise if it was a promise to you
um three years ago
uh
was no doubt sincere but various things
have happened since then
that have
have have forced us to have to rethink
that schedule
and and the work involved in
accommodating various changes along the
way and various
uh interruptions to the process
has
has resulted in in this extension
we had changes to the national planning
policy framework in 2018 we had
changes to housing numbers and we're
probably going to have changes again to
housing numbers
we had the council's own elections in
and the snap general election in late
2019 all of these contributed to a
longer time scale than we envisaged when
the previous lds was published in july
that's my short answer uh you and i
could no doubt have a
longer discussion on this subject that i
prefer to
do that after the meeting
um counselor burn you've managed to
switch your camera around we've got a
great shot of some kitchen roll and some
rubbish
on the table next to you
oh yes that's my hair fever um
hey favorite equipment
um councillor welling you have a
question
yes i do thank you very much
um
when will ward members be given an
opportunity to see what changes if any
have been made which will specifically
affect their wards
for instance changes to the allocations
map
um well that is outside the scope of the
lds uh
so it's not a relevant question to this
this meeting it's not an irrelevant
question
um
but i can't answer it uh because it's
related to the jlp and not to the lds
um
we'll be getting the council of welum
and again
talk to me outside the meeting and i'll
see if i can enlighten you a little
better
um councillor pratt
oh you've just gone counsellor field
sorry councillor pratt do you want to
ask a question or no
um i i think it may not be relevant um
it does follow on a bit uh on on what um
councillor wellam has just asked so i
will reserve my question
okay thank you councillor field
thank you it was just returning to the
issue of the schedule um
it's a matter of management to be able
to judge the time that it your desires
are likely to occur
and we're all aware of those of us who
read newspapers
that the government is intent at the
moment on changing the planning system
in a way that will accelerate progress
so i'll just return to really question
you again is this a realistic time scale
we have had a large number of them
um well yes i believe it's a realistic
timetable cancer field
the the the changes the government's uh
likely to make to accelerate the the
process
is is not going to affect
the process of the preparation of joint
local plan and and nor can we mirror
that necessarily that
speed improvement that the government is
is aiming for
um
it's
we still have work to do
and and as the lds clearly shows that um
there is that caveat
that certain things have got to go
reasonably well for us if we're to keep
that if we're to keep that schedule
but i sincerely believe
that
that we can
um we have some legal advice to take on
one or two issues
that may or may not affect the work that
we have to do may add to it or it may
say no we've done sufficient so
these are imponderables we're taking our
best guess
we're looking at risk we're looking at
all the various factors that we can
and
uh
these are the these are the dates or
these are the periods that i think we
can sincerely give to you today
sorry councillor william could you turn
your camera off please
councillor otton you have a question
thank you chairman
um yes i i'm sorry cancer burn but i'm
not convinced in fact i don't really
think you answered
um
cancer ebon's question
because on page 95 of your report it
clearly says that we will work with
other council strategies and surely
the
climate change strategy has got to be
integrated within this document um for
it to go out for public consultation so
i'm really unclear about how you intend
to fit that in and in fact at page 84
um under environmental implications um
it clearly states that an appropriate
assessment will
accomplish the joint local plan on a
strategic environment assessment
incorporating sustainability appraisal
so i really feel
that we must ensure
that what we have committed to with the
climate change
decision work is is integrated within
this
document
um
fine thank you very much councillor
orton um
at this stage i disagree with you that
it's a question that is relevant to the
lds
um
but
uh we we are accommodating
a lot of the uh climate change strategy
already in into the
uh joint local plan
um
i i think it would be useful to to ask
uh um
our assistant director uh
for growth if if he could
add anything to that to reassure you
that the climate change
strategy is being is being considered
and and
will will continue to be considered
without it necessarily affecting the the
timetable
tom would you like to
would you like to uh
say a word or two on that one to
reassure
professor rotten
council rotten
um yeah if i can if i can provide some
reassurance um officers and and members
clearly worked closely with the um
climate change task force um we attended
a number of those meetings um and
continued to ensure that
um we were working kind of hand in glove
i suppose with
the team that were preparing the action
plan so that the action plan that was
approved by
cabinets
recently
doesn't compromise the joint local plan
um we've gone as far as we feel able to
in terms of pushing environmental
measures within the joint local plan
within the context of the planning
system that
provides the rules within which we have
to operate um
so
the the joint local plan as it emerges
is
um reflecting and recognizing all of the
commitments that the council has made
towards addressing climate change
measures
some of those things will
have to be added in terms of detail
once the new joint local plan is is
adopted and and we look at supplementary
planning documents and other things like
that
but we did work closely with the task
force so that there wasn't anything
suggested within that that couldn't be
achieved through the planning system so
that it was realistic and achievable um
and just to pick up the other point
about emerging strategies
at some point
i guess
you have to submit to an examiner and
you have to continue to take every step
between where we are now and when we get
to the point of submission and we have
to try and absorb as much information as
is readily available from the council's
adopted strategies and ensure that the
local plan that is submitted for
examination
um reflects the
corporate approach of the councils
so we will endeavor to ensure that
happens
um councillor pratt have you have a
question now
yes i do and i think
i've changed my mind i think it is
indeed relevant and based on what we've
just heard um as you all know the
biodiversity task group
is is now underway and and um
is meeting every three weeks and uh
planning is one of the
uh topics that's going to be discussed
before
um september i believe um what i wanted
to know was um you know would there now
within this time frame would there be
time to debate
um planning principles
for example biodiversity net gain and
would there be time to incorporate if it
was felt um
needed would it be would it be would be
able to incorporate such measures within
the jlp
um before it's adopted
um
thank you
council pratt
i'm aware that recently you have been
you've been in email
contact with um
uh philip isbell and uh he copied me
into that
um and you have suggested that you and i
mate perhaps or i come and attend one of
your meetings
um so that we can talk about this um
outside this meeting and that at much
much greater length
um
it depends on the extent clearly as to
whether any any further work
uh that is relevant to the creation of
the jlp
can be
accommodated without extending this
timetable um as i said
paragraph 1.5
does
expect of that certain certain things
are going to go well and the various
things are not going to come up and
and
trip us up along the way
um
i'm very interested to talk to you about
your
biodiversity
net gain
and i'm very interested to see to what
extent the planning system
can
can assist in in in that
but um without knowing more
what you have in mind i don't think i'm
in a position to say now what extent it
will
likely it is likely to change that
timetable let's have that conversation
next week and
see where we can take this
um councillor fleming you have a
question
i don't have a question but i have a
comment um should we wait for a bit of
questions are we debating this um we are
debating this item but um if there's no
more questions then we can move into the
debate is there any more questions
okay well then we'll move into debate so
i'm councillor fleming you may speak now
everyone only has three minutes and
they're only allowed to speak once in
the debate
councillor ebon do you have a question
before we move into the debate
i thought you were moving to debate so
i'm just preparing my hand in the okay
right okay councillor fleming go for it
yeah okay i just want to say um and i'll
be very brief that a local development
scheme is a timetable for producing
planning documents
that will make up the local plan
um it's not we shouldn't be having a
debate about the nature of the local
plan itself because that's not relevant
to the item on our agenda
but i would like to make a comment on
some of the comments that have been made
on things like biodiversity and
adding this that and the other to the
local plan
the problem with with with this and with
life actually is that we're dealing with
constant uncertainty
and dealing with uncertainty is
something that
is challenging
but we need to deal with it but if we
don't deal with it we won't have a fully
made
joint local plan at all we need to forge
ahead
go ahead with the local plan not change
it so fundamentally that it has to go
back to consultation and review there
are ways we can bring up biodiversity
into
the planning system we've discussed
these with the green party with with
councillor pratt he's very well aware of
the intention to
to develop a supplementary planning
document in response to the work that
the biodiversity group does which is
terribly important and something which i
do not want us to rush into headlong and
do in a sort of four to six week time
frame because that wouldn't do that
subject justice these are all
conversations that we will have
afterwards and we've had before so that
that is the point that i wish to make
thank you
thank you councillor
thank you very much chair um i just um
i just hope that this isn't you know
that we don't see another timetable
really um
i i really wish you know as with many of
my fellow councillors i think across all
divides that we've got on with doing
this the joint local plan back in 2014
um and then we wouldn't be sitting here
looking at a timetable now and i really
hope that um this timetable and when it
says things like winter that by winter
we mean december rather than march or
beyond um and so
you know
i i will be supporting this um
proposal today the recommendation
um but i really want to see that we
actually do meet the timetable um and if
there are resources i've raised this
before about resources and was assured
that we had the resources to to bring
the joint local plan back to council
to now today rather than potentially you
know another few months hence in
november and yet it's been delayed again
so i really hope we've got the resources
to match um this timetable um and i just
hope that for the sake of our
communities we can
it is going to be worth it thank you
very much chair
thank you councillor mansell
uh thank you chair um i i just like to
to uh comment that we've heard quite a
lot about all the uncertainties that
have occurred um
you know that there are so many
uncertainties because there are all
these events um and issues many of which
are completely outside of our control
which have um ended up in in delay after
delay after delay for this joint local
plan and i i can only agree with
councillor ebern by saying that we
really should have gone with this back
in 2014 and i know
we're here and we haven't and we've got
to deal with it but but i i'm i'm
concerned that we're glossing over
uncertainties that we yet to have no
idea what impact they will have
on what is in our joint local plan
um and i and i
uh much as i
would hope that we can stick to a
timetable i i personally
um have lost faith in in being able to
stick to the timetable
um so i've yet to decide whether i'm
going to support this this uh this
development scheme um i think there are
so many uncertainties
and we really don't know what's going to
happen um
so i i'm not convinced that that
we should be
sticky agreeing this timetable at the
current time um you know there's just
there's just too much uncertainty and
the longer it goes on the more events
that will happen
that will um cause
possibly cause yet more delays um
uh you know there are things within the
local plan that i think will probably
need to be changed more than
insignificantly as uh councillor fleming
intimated
councillor madison
are you hearing me yes oh good
um
yes i mean
your microphone's up can you move your
mic down to your mouth i'm john
that's it sorry about that
um
yeah the
i mean i think we need we need to pass
this
um
this timetable albeit there there are it
is it will be at risk and what i want to
talk about is the
um
what we need to do about
about that risk it's it's ironic and a
few a few members have been around a
while will will remember this that the
previous local plan
was was um to some extent construct or
some of it was constructed
under a government thing called the
local development framework where we
were putting together
um
a set of
parts rather than uh one
you know one huge
um joint local plan
as we are now
and um
so what i wanted to to suggest really is
that
okay we put this timetable forward but
when we
before we get to adoption
we we actually start a review
because
realistically and i'm looking back again
to the previous plan and to this one
realistically it might easily take four
or five years from the start of a review
to actually get into adoption again and
and
on a similar theme and and um council
fleming has
hinted at this already um
i think we should we should look to
making greater use of supplementary
guidance
which becomes a planning document its
own right as well so those are the two
thoughts that i have from the experience
and and i think there's one other point
probably which that
would please will counselor burn you
know point out to the government that
it's extraordinarily difficult to
actually produce a joint local plan in
any reasonable amount of time
and um
and and that's actually largely the
government's
fault
um
so um
you know and then on the other hand of
course we're penalized if we haven't got
an up-to-date during local plan so that
they're really hitting us with with both
um both sides of it really so that's
that's what i'd like to say thank you
councillor richardson
thank you chair i wanted to make a few
brief comments and actually i have to
say i completely agree with the last
thing that councillor matherson just
said that actually the circumstances of
the production of a joint local plan is
always going to be difficult especially
when engaging with governments which
change their their planning and housing
priorities it's it's always going to be
a case of there are many moving parts to
this um but i just wanted to reflect on
the fact that from my experience on one
of the development control committees
i've been
made very much aware of the risks
associated with continuing to operate um
as a planning authority without
up-to-date planning policies um and i
noting that in the risk assessment in
the report that the impact of of not
progressing the jlp to examination would
be a disaster
so i very much welcome this this report
and this timetable and and certainly
hope that we can expedite the process
going forward so that we can have a
robust approach to planning set out uh
for the next 15 years so i very much
welcome this report and we'll be
absolutely voting in favor of it thank
you
thanks councillor field
thank you just to say that i certainly
will be supporting this
i'm sure i said in the election leaflet
some time ago how desperate it was that
we needed it
we clearly need this i just wanted to
point out that as far as i'm concerned
it needs managing we need to make sure
the resources are available and that we
get
simple things like organizing meetings
done rapidly people need to understand
its priority you know management is not
about providing a good set of excuses
when you miss the end date it's about
getting it done on time
i'm sure if i passed a jaundice view
over the time scale
i would doubt you could achieve that but
could you please prove me wrong and do
it
counselor war boys
okay i'm live am i
uh it's sort of a
a question as as much as a and a bit of
a concern it says
uh after what council fleming was saying
about um accompanying
um
documents
and looking at
11.1 the joint local plan will be
accompanied by a strategic environment
assessment incorporated to sustainable
appraisal document and and it goes on a
bit about habitats regulations and
a plan on protected habitats and
appropriate mitigation which
which looks at which i should imagine
would include biodiversity and
concerns there
and it
comes back to my experiences on the
development committees would an
accompanying
document carry the same weight
as the joint local plan or would it be
there for information but not actually
carry significant weight when it came to
assessing an application
have you got an answer to counselor burn
or is this a statement of what you think
council
counselor warboys it is it's a concern
but it could be responded to by an
answer to the question really
that would this would this accompanying
documents would they carry the same
weight in a joint local plant or should
they actually be included within the
joint local plan
um
sorry i i would have answered straight
away to that one chairman but um
i know we're not but i think i'll just
if i may please i'll just say
that the supplementary planning document
has um
can be and and will be if it's
appropriate to a particular application
as material as the joint local plan so
um i think i think you need fear not to
that any supplementary document
if it's added to the plan is a
development plan document
and is
is has has to be taken into account uh
part of the determination process
thank you thank you councillor stringer
thank you chair
uh yes just wanted to sort of uh during
the debate this is a really tricky one
because
uh
given a free choice which i have uh
would i vote for this timetable i'd
actually like to vote for a timetable
that could shorten the process
you know
from my point of view
this is
of extreme urgency that doesn't mean to
say we should agree to anything
because although as councillor
richardson said there are dire
consequences apparently to
not having
an up-to-date local plan we've seen some
of those diet consequences being enacted
in three dimensions in some of our
communities
which which is
not what many of those communities deem
as sustainable so uh it would be helpful
if
the timetable of the dire circumstances
were spelled out but equally i certainly
i think on balance i'll probably support
this document but grudgingly because i
want to see that timetable shorter and
if that means you want me to sit in
meetings through the night i don't care
we need to get this thing sped up but
not at the cost of our communities
thank you councillor passmore
thanks sir lavinia i just wanted to make
a couple of comments we do need to do
this i shall certainly be voting for it
i completely understand um
everybody's concerns about the tight
timetable but we do need to support this
because um we need to get it done so i
hope that the the officers the team
will have that real focus we've got to
make sure they've got the resources and
prioritize the work for them so it can
be delivered and just to allay some
people's concerns
if we don't do this
then various items that may be decided
by the committee or through under
delegated authority if either side
disagrees and goes to appeal um i think
we could be on a hard and do nothing if
we don't have this i agree with andrew
and everybody we need to get it right
but um let's be optimistic about it and
double our efforts redouble our efforts
and get on with it and i'm sure we will
succeed and um the fullback there of
course is a democratic principle of
committees being able to decide uh what
applications go or turn down so let's
not be too damn beat so all i want to
say let's get on with it and let's
support it thanks
thank you councillor miller
uh thank you chair i fully support uh
the plan from councillor byrne and thank
him for the amount of work on it i will
be supporting this and i accept the
comments other colleagues have made but
i think it's a genuine
effort to
make sure that the joint local plan is
produced as soon as possible so thank
you counselor byrne for all your work on
this thank you
um
thank you um
um cathy would you like to have your say
now
uh yes thank you very much well having
been on one of the working groups um
producing this or assisting to produce
this
i agree with what people are saying we
do need to get it moved forward and i
shall be supporting it
thank you councillor berm is there
anything else you'd wish to add
um
yes uh
let me say that um
i've i've appreciated and even enjoyed
this debate um
because i think it's brought out some
some good strong feelings i'm i'm
disappointed with one or two of those
feelings but much heartened
by
others um
uh i was particularly interested
to to
listen to counselor matheson's comments
uh
certainly talking of reviewing the the
plan
as as
soon as we've submitted it
yes i think that's in everybody's mind
is to
get on pretty pretty quickly with a
review because
um times
uh
have changed and are continuing to
change quite quickly um so we we do need
to uh get on to
accommodating those changes
as he points out it is extraordinarily
difficult to produce a local plan in any
reasonable time frame and that is partly
the the government's
responsibility and yes i'll be happy to
make the necessary representations to
government
um
councillor mansell i'm
i i'm sorry was was as as pessimistic as
she seemed as she sounded
uh i i hope she isn't as pessimistic as
that in the in the long run
uh
councillor field on the other hand
showed an optimism that that i um
i approved of
but uh and he pointed out that um
it needs
managing it needs
being it needs resourcing adequately
which is definitely something that we uh
i'm keen to make sure happens
the management of it we have a pro
program board which looks very closely
at
this on a on a regular basis
scrutinizes the the progress and takes
whatever steps are necessary at that
time and i hope
i hope it is sensitive enough to react
to any any changing circumstance and to
react to it quickly and positively
so um
i think the bottom line is to follow uh
counselor personal
um
urging and that is let's be optimistic
let's get the job done
and let's prove to um
cancer feel that he's wrong and we'll do
it
thank you very much i'm afraid council
or boys you can't speak again and i will
now ask the corporate manager for
governance and civic officer to take a
roll call vote
thank you chair members please can you
reply with full against or abstain
counsellor morrison
councillor morrison
four did just answer hello can you hear
me
yeah we can hear you yeah thank you four
councillor brewster
four
councillor
field
four councillor flatman
four councillor fleming
four
councillor geek
four councillor gould
four
councillor guthrie
councillor hattingham four councillor
hicks
four councillor humphreys
four
councillor mansell abstain
councillor madison
four
councillor mellon
four that's a mayor
four councillor morley
four councillor muller four councillor
norris four councillor otton four that's
a pass
four councillor phillips
four councillor pratt
four councillor richardson
four that's a scarf four that's a
stringer
four faster
cancer
[Music]
thank you
that
that was
carried
moving on to agenda item number 14
mc-19-50
political balance and composition of the
committees i would like to invite the
monitoring officer to introduce this
paper
thank you chair i would like to present
the report mc1950
which seeks the council's approval of
the political balances of committees
which have been amended following the
formation of the green and liberal
democrat group
as the overall allocation of places has
not changed there have been no proposed
changes to the council as appointed to
each committee
as such recommendation 2.2 is no longer
required
i therefore seek a proposer and seconder
for recommendation 2.1 only thank you
have i got a proposal
counselor eben
thank you
thank you very much um chair um it will
be a pleasure for me to propose this
recommendation of 2.1 only um and um as
this has come about from us
forming a group with the liberal
democrats which i'm delighted to do um
and between us now our new group
constitutes half the council and we look
forward to working more closely with the
conservative and independent group um
from
in the future and i'd like to ask um
councillor john field to second thank
you
oh
i'm very happy to do that
similar set of words
thank you very much
um is there any questions or um
or um any questions
or debate
um so we'll move straight on to the vote
then i'll ask the corporate manager for
governance and civic office to take a
roll call vote
thank you chair members please can you
reply with four against or abstain
councillor and morrison
or
cancer brewster
four councillor byrne
chancellor byrne
councillor byrne you're mike you're
muted
just just
move your lips
i'll take that before cancer carter
[Music]
or counselor caston or councillor ebern
four councillor epignon
four cancer field
four councillor flatman four councillor
fleming
four
cancer geek
four cancer gould
four answer guthrie
for
councillor hadingham for councillor
hicks four councillor humphreys
four councillor mansell for councillor
madison
four councillor mellon
four councillor mayor
four councillor morley four councillor
muller four councillor norris four
that's not otton four cancer pass more
four cancer phillips
four cancer pratt
four councillor richardson four cancer
scarf paul cancer stringer four cancer
turner
four cancer warboys four councillor
welum four
councillor whitehead four
i think that was carried
so we're moving on to um item number 15
counselor appointments are there any
changes to placings
there aren't any so we'll move straight
on to um item number 16 motions on
notice so um item number 16 a to
consider the motion on notice received
from councillor pratt
rules of debate on motions under part 3
of the constitution paragraph 17 each
council have three minutes to speak
apart from the proposed proposal of the
motion or the proposal of an amendment
who shall have five minutes and may
speak once on any motion however if a
motion is amended a counselor may speak
once on each amendment i would like to
invite councillor pratt to move the
motion thank you chair um so the covet
19 lockdown event has highlighted how
walking
and cycling either to get to work or to
the shops or indeed for fitness and
leisure
has become increasingly important to our
residents
the benefits of active travel
are self-evident in terms of reduced air
pollution safer and less congested roads
and the positive effects on our health
and well-being
in may the uh
transport secretary grant shaps said
when the country gets back to work we
need them to carry on cycling and to be
joined by millions more
um
very very powerful um little soundbite
really um
in their paper decarbonizing transport
the government has set to aim to double
cycling activity per person per year
and are set to invest a further 1.2
billion in active modes of transport
such as walking and cycling
and regrettably the the department of
transport statistics show in mid-suffolk
that the proportion of adults
uh cycling for the purpose of transport
has rapidly declined over the years the
proportion of adults that circle for the
purpose of travel
at a frequency of three times per week
fell from five percent in 2015
to less than half a percent in 2018.
unfortunately our cycling rates
are amongst the lowest in suffolk and
and far below national average
to reach so therefore to reach the
national cycling target we require an
ever more ambitious approach to make
sci-fi cycling a safer and more
attractive
mode of transport
our council
in no doubt recognizes the benefits that
walking and cycling and other forms of
active transport can have on our health
and well-being
physical inactivity is one of the top 10
causes of disease and disability in
england
for many people the easiest and most
accepted form of physical activity
are those that can be incorporated
easily into everyday life such as
walking or cycling
the reduction of traffic and congestion
also conveys
a health benefit through reducing
pollutants
such as nitrogen dioxide
and pm 2.5 which we understand is a
general
contributor to human health impacts
across the country
but not least we must consider our
obligations to tackling climate change
in 2019 mid-south district council
acknowledged the existential threat
posed by greenhouse emissions and
declared a climate emergency
in the same year
transport was the largest emitting
sector accounting for around one third
or 34
of all carbon dioxide emissions most of
these emissions were from road transport
so by encouraging active transport
as opposed to driving a car
we can play an important role in
reducing the carbon footprint of our
residents
the the significance of this modal shift
in transport for reducing
emissions must not really be understated
this is why we are asking mid-suffolk
district council to publish plans that
set out our vision for cycling in the
area it will help ensure cycle routes
and facilities are in place to create a
safe and attractive environment that
will encourage people to cycle
and recognize cycling as a viable
transport option
and afford the opportunity to enjoy
their outdoor surroundings
in order to bid for government funding
for these projects we must ensure that
we have a prioritized and costed list of
routes
across the district that we can work
through with suffolk county council
we should utilize our district level
knowledge of the locality and work with
parish councils community groups and
local businesses so that we can help
gain local consensus on where
infrastructure is most needed
the district council can also play a
role by ensuring that additional funding
measures can be used to develop and
develop deliver schemes
which could also
include community funds and where
appropriate include development charges
such as section 106 and sell
um as we seek a new normal in
post-covert times it is essential that
we in a we seek innovative and pragmatic
approaches to encourage walking and
cycling to expedite the decarbonisation
of transport
it is on this basis that i'm asking you
to support this motion thank you
um thanks um could i have a seconder
councillor mansell
uh thank you chair i i i would be more
than happy to second this motion um and
i reserve my right to speak
thank you
so um who would like to start first with
questions
anyone
um counselor morrison
thank you chair can you hear me yes i
can yeah
um
would it it was i think it was brushed
on in this um motion
um how much would um behavior change
schemes be a part of this proposal
such as the schemes
offered by
charities such as susterans
where they
they engage with businesses and schools
to
promote cycling so it's not just about
infrastructure it's about behavior
change
cancer personal
um thanks david i just wanted to
get some clarification if possible
is it the case at the moment that we
cannot finance any um cycling schemes or
improvements through the seal or the 106
agreement
i thought we could already do that but i
may be wrong
i don't know if an officer could answer
that please for information so we all
know
any officers wanting to answer that
anyone tom tom mike
tom are you still there
i am
i am still here
um sorry
uh
yes just to just to clarify on sill um
we can't use sil because
cycling and highway improvements are not
part of our civil um expenditure list
we will be going through a review of the
charging schedule which was part of the
last item but we will also be going
through a review of the expenditure
framework so it's something that can be
considered as part of the review of the
expenditure framework
in terms of section 106 yes absolutely
we have and do secure funds for footpath
improvements cycleway improvements
highway improvements
as part of that all capital items
and no maintenance contribution but yes
we've collected significant sums of
money
as an example one specific 243 000
collected from the children lee's
development to
enable linkages into footpaths that will
um
enhance walking opportunities
good so just to be clear tom thank you
for that so there is funding available
at the moment as we speak potentially
there is yeah thank you very much thank
you lavinia
thank you councillor fleming
yes thank you um
first off i'd just like to say i really
appreciate the um
good intent behind this motion
but um
i have proposed an amendment to it
um and for convenience this amendment
has been tabled for the meeting
um councillors
should therefore have her copy in front
of them already or should have received
a copy and with the chairman's
permission
i would like a copy to be brought on
screen please if that was possible yeah
it's just been put on jess
thank you very much um
can everyone see this
or do i need to read it out
well can everyone see this i'm thinking
yes i can see it
if anyone would like me to read it then
please
speak and i can read it out please do
sorry
we can all see it
good stuff
everyone can see it
um
yep
good on on that basis then
um
i would like to um describe
the reasons for um for my proposal to to
make this amendment
um
as cabinet member for the environment
i'm very supportive the original motion
um but the amendments i have proposed
are intended to widely widen its scope
and stimulate more targeted actions
the shift to more sustainable travel
fits well with our recently agreed
climate change action plan
will feed into our future well-being
strategy
it also fits with the government's
decarbonising transport white paper
recently published
and the new angular local enterprise
partnerships local industrial strategy
which has a focus on clean growth
the sustainable
i'm proposing a sustainable travel
action plan rather than a cycling
strategy
now this approach will enable
a wider
view of
modal shift and will ensure that public
transport and walking are included as
well in the initiatives this is more in
keeping with the collaborative approach
being taken by suffolk county council
which is the lead transport authority is
likely to be a key partner
i believe that this wider approach to
achieving modal shift
is most likely to show the sort of
results we all want
we are just starting to emerge from the
covid
pandemic which while it provided an
opportunity for more outdoor exercise in
the form of walking and cycling has also
shaken people's confidence in public
transport
and much need
will need to be done to overcome this in
the near future
the sustainable trans travel action plan
will enable initiatives to be identified
assessed and developed into meaningful
projects which can be then costed
consulted upon and substitute subject to
securing funding
and appropriate partners
can actually be delivered
this approach will enable us to consider
new initiatives such as e-scooters and
e-bikes
to promote walking and cycling for a
wide variety of purposes including
encouraging children to walk and cycle
safely to school
we are all committed to getting more
people active in our communities
and our council aims to lead the way in
developing sustainable travel across
suffolk
therefore i am proposing the amended
motion tonight to full cons council
and i call for a seconder
i'm happy to second chair
i'm pleased to the amendment amended
motion which has been explained so
eloquently to members by councillor
fleming
as cabinet member for communities which
includes health and wellbeing i welcome
the sustainable travel action plan which
complements the work this council
commenced last year supporting schools
in delivering a walk run and cycle to
school initiative
this was part of an overall strategy
active schools to deliver more exercise
sport and healthy lifestyle to primary
aged children
working with our partners suffolk sport
and public health
with child obesity in england at an
all-time high and growing
families need safe travel routes to have
the confidence to use them
this will contribute to a holistic
health and well-being and improve air
quality which we have all enjoyed over
the past four months
we all need exercise to maintain good
health and this has become more obvious
to many of us while spending all our
working hours looking and talking at the
screen
i know from my own experience a brisk
walk was a tonic which kept me sane
thank you chair
um thank you councillor pratt you accept
this amendment
um
yes yes i do um
i did i did wish to um
looking at that amendment
um
i'm just just wondering whether you know
the wording around sufficient resource
includes um
more more officer time as well because
because clearly this is such a mammoth
task
we we do need to make sure that we're
dedicating enough enough time and
allocating enough time for our officers
in order to in order to undertake this
this work
sorry hang on one second
okay so um so that that's then moved um
that's become the substantive motion
motion yes that's right um so we can
move to debate or questions
counselor morley what would you like to
speak
i wonder whether i can make a suggestion
on the first paragraph
where it says
mid-suffolk district council endorses
the government's goal to ensure there is
a permanent shift in the numbers of
people choosing to cycle and walk full
stop
and remove the last
five words
we don't need the bit about as opposed
to using a car
thank you thank you chair
that would have to be proposed and
seconded apparently is another amendment
uh chair i'm happy to propose or second
that if that's necessary
i'm i'm prepared
sorry it's um can you hear me now
yes
councillor morley would you like to
propose that as a second amendment yes i
would please thank you okay have i got a
second uh
yes uh chair unhappy to second
oh cool thank you um councillor
richardson
daniel to accept that
amendment
um
i won't because uh i feel that you know
i don't see the the point really in in
having a motion that's um trying to
stimulate and encourage a modal shift
towards active modes of transport and
away from the car
um
you know
and then
but by admitting admitting um
emitting that line would would kind of
like take away
the the sort of spirit of it really
wouldn't it
that's that's your that's some
your opinion i guess
so you're not going to accept that but
you accepted the original one i accept
the first i accept the first amendment
but not the second
hang on so we're gonna move to debate
then
on the amendment on the amendment so um
susie i see you've got your hand up
again do you want to speak again
so susie would you like to speak
thank you thank you chair um i just
thought i'd i'd um
just expand a bit on my rationale for
saying that
um
it's not just
to
persuade people out of their cars
the the the rationale is that we need to
get our people
exercising more
chair sorry full stop
can i have a point of order please chair
um sorry could have
can you hear me sorry um
i hear you rachel um
please because i thought that if um the
proposer has rejected the
amendment we should be debating um
the amendment that he's agreed which is
councillor fleming's amendment i think
you're right hang on at least um so with
councilman emily's just gonna come in
hang on one second if councillor molly
wanted to um debate
that's fine
yeah hang on emily's now going to come
in
thank you chair uh so the situation is
that we had a a first amendment uh
proposed and seconded
against the original motion
that was accepted by the proposer of the
original motion so that has now become
the substantive motion
subsequent to that we've had a second
amendment put which has been proposed or
seconded so now the council will need to
debate
the second amendment which is to remove
the five
words from the first sentence
uh and
uh
and vote on whether that need will be um
taken forward or not as the proposer of
the uh original motion hasn't accepted
the amendment
hopefully that makes sense chair
it um
yes so um i've got um jess down next
um
yes
i mean i i'll be quite honest i don't
think those um few words
alter the intent of of the um of the
motion at all and i think
um you know whichever one we had it has
the same import
so i would just urge good sense and for
us to carry this forward and
and do what you know i think is a very
sensible thing by
getting the gist of it
approved
thank you um counselor madison
thank you chair
pull your mic down john
right um sorry yes
the
the point is that modal shift and as as
counselor pratt has said modal shift is
absolutely fundamental to
the the karma the carbon
benefits
um
both in terms of the the broader
government
intent
to um to you know to achieve zero carbon
eventually
and um
and to our intention to do that
and and to the
the benefits of reducing car use is is
what is going to produce the reduction
of air pollution
so
all things considered the phrase is very
important and very necessary thank you
counselor mansell sorry about that
uh thank you chair um yes i am i i i
can't really see any need or
for removing those those words at the
end of the first sentence those to me
are vital because um there is a huge
divide many people who aren't cyclists
aren't aware that there is a divide
between leisure cycling and utility
cycling and what we actually need people
to do is to be using their bikes or
walking as their mode of transport not
to shove their bikes in the back of a
car drive to a lovely bit of bike path
and have a leisure cycle ride we need
people to be getting out of their cars
onto their bikes or walking
to improve the health well-being of our
communities to improve air pollution
there is no way that those five words
should be removed they are to me
some of the most important words in the
in the document we need to get people
out of their cars
into a more healthy and sustainable way
of getting about so no i cannot support
uh this amendment uh because i think
that is the most important thing to do
is to actually get people to be using a
bike as a mode of transport
not to use their car if the shop is only
a couple of miles away we need them to
be able to get on their bikes to get to
the shop and not hop in a car drive to
their co-op come back again and then go
out for a bike ride and think oh yeah
i'm doing the right thing i'm on my bike
they need to be using that bike for
those short journeys within their
communities that is vital otherwise it's
just not going to happen it's so easy to
fit in if you need to go to the shop you
do your exercise you walk or you cycle
to the shop and you come back again we
don't want to be getting in the car and
taking your bikes or getting in the car
and going for a walk this is all about a
more sustainable way of transport
um councillor burn
dave we can hear you you've got you
you're unmuted yeah
just just it's just a muted so um so it
was a point of order but i think the
time has passed so i'll i'll i'll forgo
my
form forgot my place thank you
councillor carter
terrence you're muted
i do apologize i didn't realize i'd been
called your phrase for a second on my
screen
um yeah
to me
removing those words is about as
barbaric as declawing your cat it kind
of
it defeats the point of actually you
have very nice and pretty we have we've
been shown we have this lovely animal
but it's we've taken away all the uh all
the
well the necessity for it
it's just it's just a it's
a pretty picture
we need to actually be showing that we
are trying to move away from this as a
form of
this motion we also are opening up for
further things long line up about if we
are having e-scooters why not further in
longer line of
the mobility scooter network of
improving the transport for to say
disability as well having this there
it
allows for
more than just how uh more than just
taking a
removing a car and opening up for our
performance of transport it has that
there
um
all very good if we were all going over
to cars that are electric cars but if we
are keeping cars in there and still got
the carbon we we are
still having the same uh same issues the
air quality is still there and also this
with all because
you will find people will not cycle
due to the amount of
traffic on the roads due to amount of
the
the air quality when you're cycling you
actually are breathing in the fumes
of the class you are if there's been
safety as well when you're
cycling if you see lots of cars about
it's off-putting
so if we do need two-pronged approach we
do need to need
to get people to
cut down on their driving as well as
improving on the cycling so removing
those words it's just
will be pointless having the motion
councillor wellam
thank you chair i will be very brief
um the wording is we want to ensure
there is a permanent shift we've got to
say what the permanent shift is away
from so it's essential that we use those
words
shifting away from
using a car so those words stay in my
view
um thank you um
did keith um freeze
am i frozen
counselor brewster sorry
um
yes listening to what's being said
um i think
uh opposition members
of the fact that we are a rural district
um there are some people who
obviously need their cars to to access
wherever
and certainly to go shopping i would
suggest
i've seen people actually shopping
and they would need a very very very big
basket on their bike to take home what
their what they are buying
by
keeping that in
we are
really
making people feel guilty
if they
can't use their car to to
to access the needs they want
and that doesn't mean that
um
that
they perhaps won't cycle
but i i think it just makes it's it's
it's a guilt feeling by leaving it into
this um
into this motion
uh
we are very wide district and and
there's so many people who still
will need to use their cars i'm sorry
that is a fact of life
thank you um jess
am i muted
councillor fleming hello yes so i was
just unmuting
um
i believe
it probably would be legitimate of me to
propose
that we go to the vote on
the
amendment that i
um actually referred to and spoke on and
that is
the um
the text that everyone has seen before
you can you can go to the vote on suzy's
amendment of your amendment if you like
we can do that
well
um what i'm proposing is to go to the
vote on what i spoke on because i
haven't spoken on susan you can't do
that no you can't do that we can go to
the vote on susie's amendment of the
amendment
that's what we can do now if we'd like
to
okay could i have my point of order back
please
who's speaking well can't
this was my point of order as an
amendment to what had become the
substantive motion
should not counselor fleming have been
asked
whether she accepted
councillor molly's amendment
no this it's daniel's thing
no
the substantive motion
i'm being told david that it's um that
it's um emily's saying emily's gonna
speak
we're just waiting for emily to be
unmuted
our chair yeah
thank you and and again counselors i
apologize for for that delay
uh so if i can just recap where we are
with with the motion
um
councillor pratt seconded by councillor
mansell proposed the original motion
councillor fleming then proposed an
amendment which was accepted by
councillor pratt that means the uh
substantive motion has now been amended
as suggested by councillor fleming
and remains in the ownership if you if
you will of councillor pratt
so councillor pratt and council and
mancella are now still the sec the
proposer and seconder but of the amended
motion which now becomes the substantive
motion
we then had a second amendment uh
proposed by councillor morley seconded
by councillor richardson which the
council is debating now
because you need to vote on that before
you can return to the substantive motion
which may or may not be amended
depending on the outcome of a vote
thank you chair
so we're now going to go to councillor
morley
thank you chair i
when i proposed this
um
i didn't have a chance to explain my
reasoning because i was in interrupted
by
uh councillor ebern with a point of
order so i i'm taking this as my
opportunity to speak just to explain my
rationale
for me
living close to the a140a 1120
crossroads
cycling
is not an option to get out of where i
live
and as part of their health and
well-being strategy
the initiative is to get people moving
as quickly as possible
not only does that help support
keeping them healthier and fitter
but of course it does
reduce the use of the car
however
i am willing to withdraw my amendment
and go back to the substantive
amendment as proposed by councillor
fleming
thank you
thank you um councillor stringer
yeah pretty much what i was going to say
has never been superseded by events i
just wanted to mention that the first
line in that motion was quoting stated
government policy so by amending that
first line we at mid suffolk district
council is amending what one of the
clearly stated aims of this government
are now we may be quite powerful at
mid-suffolk but i didn't think we were
quite that powerful
thanks um council the field
thank you
i was going to point out i think we have
an excellent motion
and council fleming has produced a
really good amendment to that which
widened its scope somewhat
a great value to us
and we have a motion which fits in with
the government's intentions and with the
county council's intentions
that has achieved some modal shift
and that modal shift is largely
when you travel to work or travel to
school
so it clearly involves
moving out of your car
and if you're going to persuade me to do
that
you probably need to make me feel a bit
guilty
so i suggest
we get on with it and we we
move ahead with this motion now
chairman
chairman i'd like to interrupt please
because councillor morley said she was
prepared to remove her amendment and if
that's the case then we go to the full
substantive motion do we not
we do i'm proposing we go to the vote
okay um should we do that
we're gonna we're gonna we're meant to
be debating
um
if you are going to the um
uh vote on the um substantive motion
which is now the revised motion that
that council fleming um proposed then i
still i'm entitled to my my three
minutes so um are we still in debate or
are we um coming up to the end of the
debating period
councillor pratt i'm going to say it's
up to you
um i just wanted um sorry i've just been
told councillor fields has proposed a
to vote
so we need a second have we got a second
uh for councillor field proposing that
we go to the vote
second it
john matherson all right thank you john
you can speak now and so can cancer
pratt no one else so go for it counselor
mansell
sorry i'll put i'll put my video on um i
think that that should be on
am i on yeah yes i i am i'm i'm
extremely pleased to to second this
motion um uh as you as most of you uh
members are aware um of my passion for
cycling and my passion for sustainable
transport so i would try not to to
enthuse too much about my own personal
uh beliefs on this um and i and and to
be honest i i i am actually extremely
welcoming to councillor fleming's
amendment because
i think it it it brings in um walking um
as well as uh public transport into our
our cycling motion and i and i think
that this is the right way to go in
order to
maybe get some way towards having a
truly integrated sustainable transport
network i mean we in in suffolk are
extremely lucky uh we have we have the
ideal um
countryside really for people that
should be um
easier for cyclists to to get to to
grips with we don't have a lot of steep
hills
you know we have wide open skies we have
beautiful countryside it is it is a
wonderful feeling to to have have you
know to be out on the road um
you know
we we there are there shouldn't be that
many barriers to people getting out on
their bikes and i i completely
appreciate what counselors brewster and
councillor morley said about the fact
that in some rural parts of our district
people will still need a car i'm not
denying that people will still need a
car but the more people we can to get
out on their bikes as a mode of
transport we're not if you live in if
you live in the middle of high suffolk
and you have a 10 mile journey to get to
the supermarket no i'm not expecting you
to get on your bike and carry your
shopping in the basket
but if you live in stone market
you should be able to cycle to the
center of stone market safely uh um in
order to be able to access the
facilities in the town centre as i said
before two to three miles there's the
sort of journeys that that really should
be should not be being used by the car
so
as i said before it's it's it's this is
not going to be an easy goal to make but
you know there is this divide between
leisure cycling and utility cycling uh
and i think an awful lot of people have
taken to the to their bikes uh during
this pandemic period and a lot of them
have enjoyed being out on their bikes
i've seen an awful lot of new cyclists
out on the road and i gather it's
actually now quite hard to buy a bike uh
because they are in short supply there's
long waiting list for some bikes so
people are using their bikes and we
really want to make sure that they carry
on using their bikes we've all
appreciated those wonderful clear skies
um and and the the wildlife i mean i
i've actually heard rare birds in my
garden
uh and i'm sure that that is all part
partly due to the fact that we've had
less traffic during this lockdown period
so we really expect there is something
to um encourage people to stay on their
bikes and to use them um as their as a
mode of transport if it is at all
possible so i would urge you all to vote
for this motion thank you very much
um thank you um right go for it
councillor pratt
right yeah i'll be i'll just be really
brief and um i have i have listened to
the arguments and taken those comments
on board
um and and it's i i absolutely agree
with um
with everyone else it's not about it's
not about uh saying that people should
never use a car um there will always be
times that you know it's more
appropriate to use a car of course what
this is about is
um improving people's quality of life um
through
enabling and facilitating
the uh utilization of this beautiful
countryside as council mansell
rightly pointed out um you know and and
uh for the benefit of everyone's health
and indeed to to
enable that shift um towards active
transport
um i would just like to quickly take uh
a moment to personally thank
uh councillor fleming as well for her
wonderful amendments uh on on the motion
uh it really has broadened the scope um
and i i think that that's a
that has that has enriched the motion um
so
you know just on the back of what
council announcer was saying um
please do support this motion
um thank you
um thanks right i'll now ask the
corporate manager for governance and
civic office to take a roll call vote
thank you chair members please can you
reply with four against or abstain
counsellor ammar ammar orrisson
four councillor brewster
four hamster burn
can you put your hand up to to
to acknowledge that thank you councillor
carter
four councillor castin
for councillor ebern
for councillor pinyong
or cancer field four cancer flatman four
councillor fleming
four councillor geek
four that's the gold
four
councillor guthrie four that's for
hattingham four
councillor hicks four councillor
humphreys
four councillor mansell four councillor
madison four that's the melon
four that's the mayor
four
pratt four councillor richardson
four cancer scarf four cancer stringer
four cancer turner
four cancer war boys four cancer willem
four cancer white heads
four
thank you
that was um carried
that was unanimous in fact
um all right so where are we that's some
16b
um i would like to invite um to consider
the motion on notice received from
counselor ebern i would like to invite
councillor ebon to move the motion
and can please um counselors have you
got your mics open please can you turn
them off
and um yep that daniel can you turn your
video off thank you
um thank you chair this motion is to
halt all future investments in the
council's commercial investment arms
ifco
there are three reasons why tifko's a
deeply flawed concept in both principle
and execution
first it's not the role of local
government to become involved in
commercial property speculation a
district council is there to serve the
public and provide public services nor
is it the role of the public works loan
board to lend money for this type of
activity obtaining funds in this way has
always been a dubious exercise in
exploiting a loophole which has finally
been recognised by government select
committees the clues in the name public
works
investing in assets such as housing
which will deliver benefits for the
people in this district who elected us
it was never intended that these loans
would be used to fund a speculative arms
length commercial subsidiary
secondly cifico is flawed as a matter of
risk and competence as an organisation
we do not have the competence and
capabilities necessary to manage the
considerable complexities and risks
involved in commercial property
investment people spend years and years
in training in these roles
it's not sufficient to say that we've
pushed these risks away into an arms
length vehicle and outsourced
responsibility for management to
consultants and advisers not least
because we cannot push away the
liability cifco incurs upon all of the
council taxpayers we represent
it's our responsibility the decisions
are still ours and made by us
when the vote to establish co was made i
will recall in council one fellow
conservative councillor asking whose
ultimate liability this was and i'll
never forget the look on his face when
it's confirmed that any liability will
rest with the people who elected him
potentially all 50 million pounds of it
thirdly cifco is flawed as a matter of
priority back in 2016 when sifko was
conceived we were discussing how to
build more housing for vulnerable adults
market housing for young people to start
off in life housing for key workers
these were still our pressing concerns
yet the focus went on setting up cifco
and playing the commercial property
market since when was it right to buy
commercial property in southampton in
epsom in lincoln or for rural district
council to own office blocks and car
showrooms and an m s and since when was
it right to do these things in
preference to investing in housing
within the district you may feel
disinclined to listen to me but you
should listen to your constituents this
is the area of the council's operations
that generates our largest postback
frequently from those who tell us they
vote a conservative but cannot believe
the council is making these investments
and are desperate for it to stop and
frequently from those who work in this
area in the city in finance and property
i cannot stress enough the sense of
incredulity we get when people hear
about this the message is always the
same why are counselors doing this it's
not their role they don't have the
competence they should not be exposing
us to this risk they should be investing
in the district in things such as
housing and it seems the more
professionally qualified in matters of
finance the person is the greater their
sense of alarm or outrage that a local
district council is risking their money
playing the space so how do we get to
the position where it was thought right
or over three times the annual budget to
buy a commercial property why did it
happen that our council a public body
accountable to its residents ended
borrowing so much to engage in
activities so far removed from its own
purpose
the argument as our recall was that we
needed income to replace central
government funding
noting it was a conservative government
that slashed funding to local government
in the first place however as council we
have consistently underspent our budget
and for many years have been squirreling
away reserves which as of march this
year at
17.7 million
this is seven million pounds more than
in 2016 when we started talking about
cifco
so even so how else could we increase
our income if we'd started building
housing in 2016 we would have built
several hundred by now each of these
homes would have been built by someone
who lived here who earned their money
here and spent money in mid-suffolk's
economy each of these homes would have
housed someone paying council tax and
each of these homes would have earned
new homes bonus the government's housing
incentive of about 1500 pounds each we'd
have been able to help with the housing
numbers in our forthcoming joint local
plan and supported our five-year housing
land supply we wouldn't have lost
control over housing development over
the wrong housing in the wrong places
we'd have been able to have real
discussions with our communities about
what their local housing need is
creating the market homes that
communities wanted and that developers
weren't providing we'd have had a good
partnership delivering for everyone it's
time to call time on this madness stop
throwing good money after bad to listen
to our electorate to invest in our
communities i know that many of you in
the conservative group are deeply
uncomfortable with sifco and deep down
you know it's a flawed endeavor that we
should that should never have happened
you cannot be deaf to the concerns of
your constituents or to your own common
sense
and you know how much of a relief it
will be to be able to say that this
thing is being halted now you have the
opportunity you can make a new start and
vote with me for this motion and we can
build a better more sustainable mid
suffolk that we all believe in thank you
and i'd like to invite andrew stringer
to second it thank you chair
councillor stringer yeah thank you i
would like to second this motion and i'd
like to resign reserve my right to speak
thank you
okay so we'll move into um debate
is that right debate
um so who would like to speak first i'm
councillor madison
thank you chair um yeah i've so you can
only speak once for three minutes yeah
no it's all fine
i
um you're hearing me yes that's good
um yeah i've got a number points to make
about uh sifko uh but i shall be
reserving most of those for the um
discussion of the um business plan which
is following
except for one and that is just to
remind the the our director of sifko our
our elected director of sifko and indeed
our elected directors of the um
mid-suffolk uh holding company which
holds our shares
um that they really need to have a good
close look at the
responsibilities that they have which
are indeed set out in the
um in the annual report of sifko um to
the 31st of march 2019
um
notably the uh making an assessment of
the company's ability to continue as a
going concern
uh bearing in mind that the
uh what the government has
made very clear that it wants councils
to stop
uh investing in commercial property for
for yield that's all thank you
thanks um
councillor passmore
thank you lavinia yes i think um
rachel's comments earlier about that one
counselor who had deep reservations that
was in fact me um
and i do have deep reservations
absolutely and i completely empathize
with some of the comments made
having said all that um
i think the great difficulty you've got
now
is if you were to pull it as proposed i
think that would leave an even greater
black hole in what we're doing
so i can't support this motion um
despite my reservations which i did
articulate very clearly at the time
because i think it's rather damn
difficult but let me make this quite
clear
any future investment decisions jolly
world better get the returns promised i
know nothing is completely risk-free
but as i said at the time the lender of
last resort is all of us the taxpayer so
those people who are making these
decisions
need to cut the mustard very very
clearly it's a very difficult time um
yes it was a conservative government
that cut funding to local authority but
i think the country has been one hell of
a mess and i didn't actually think there
was a great deal of alternative
and now look at the national debt we've
got quite understandable billions and
billions have been thrown at the covered
problem so
we are in a bit of a cleft stick here i
think we have to stick with this but i
want to be very very clear i'm doing
that with my eyes open i'm not um
nullifying my reservations um but this
this company has really really got to
perform and get the return that we were
all promised at the beginning
and as i say the lender of last resort
is the taxpayer and some of us maybe all
of us will remember what happened about
15 years ago when we had these
half-baked schemes of investing overseas
which we never did at mid-suffolk this
is not the same situations that
um
i just wanted to share those comments um
so that people know where we are going
but i'm afraid i'm not going to support
the motion for those very reasons thank
you lavinia
thanks i'm councillor mansell
uh
thank you um
thank you chair uh yeah i i i can only
endorse uh all of those comments made by
council eben in her opening speech the
this uh the the whole cifco um
uh investment program is the single most
um
uh
comment i get um from my parish councils
every time i go to a parish council
meeting they ask me about cifco and when
are we going to stop investing it now
that it's hit the national press um and
and they are beginning to clamp down
on this sort of uh activity
uh it is every every month um you we get
asked about um cifco and what we're
gonna do to stop it i really don't envy
you the conservatives um as to how you
answer those questions you know i have
an easy way out because i i just say uh
you know we're doing our best and i
didn't vote for it in the first place
councillor passmore as quite rightly
said it is the taxpayer uh who has the
ultimate liability we are there
representing those taxpayers and we
really should be doing our damndest to
uh do what they want us to and sorry in
my patch they clearly don't want us to
be investing in businesses outside of
our district so i will be supporting
this motion
um
thank you very much uh
i'm i'm grateful uh actually for this
motion to the council
uh not because it's a good motion making
a sensible proposal
in my view it's neither of those things
i think its value lies in the
misunderstandings
it reveals about our investment activity
let me explain
the first misunderstanding concerns the
consequences of having
pacifico investments
sifko has provided the councils with
over three million
net income since its inception in 2017.
it's made full debt repayment to the
council in march and june
providing much needed income
to the council during the pandemic
halting investment in
cifco acquisitions would reduce the
income
anticipated in the
in the medium-term financial strategy
and put further financial pressure on
the council at a time when income from
other sources
such as planning building control and so
on has reduced because of the pandemic
this motion
may be considered
uh
adequate uh inadequate and arguably
irresponsible in that it doesn't make
its decision contingent on an assessment
of the financial consequences for the
council
income generated by cifco supports the
council in delivering frontline services
and projects within the districts the
view has been expressed we've heard it
again this evening that through pacifico
we are investing in businesses outside
of our area
this is itself is a misunderstanding
we are not investing in those businesses
but taking their money in the form of
rent
so that we can spend that money
here in mid-suffolk
we all understand that no investment is
without risk but the
key consideration is the action we take
to avoid minimize or manage
those risks
and any risk has to be put against the
benefits achievable
we've taken
a wide variety of measures to manage
risk
the portfolio is professionally managed
by those
people uh referred to by counselor eben
left peter
okay
uh
completing the plan investment
diversifies the portfolio uh further in
terms of exposure to any one
tenant or sector helping to mitigate
risk further
um
the other point i want to make is is
that there's a suggestion being made
that
uh investing in commercial property is
an either or to investing in housing it
isn't and actually we are doing it i'm
afraid
in this district thank you chad
um councillor mellon
thank you chair
um i'd like to take a couple of minutes
to explain why i feel that we should
pause further investment in cifco
the recent performance of cifco's
commercial investments have been
inversely affected by the the
pandemic lockdown this we know
however things were going wrong long
before that the most recent report
shows that rent arrears in the first
quarter of 2020 were already running at
27.14
and we didn't go into lockdown until
right at the end of that quarter at the
end of march
now since then we all know what's
happened
a collapse in commercial activity in
many sectors and a massive change in how
we buy things online is up the high
street is down
and also there's been a considerable
change in our working culture away from
the office towards home working
therefore less
likely future demand for office space
so they've been massive changes
and as my accountant is fond of saying
when the tide goes out you find out who
has been swimming naked
it seems to me that sifko is one costume
short of the required amount
the businesses financial situation which
was already starting to look troubled
has lurched into uncharted territory
yet reading the most recent report which
is discussed at scrutiny and at the
cabinet you would think that there isn't
much of a problem
there is a huge amount of positive spin
being applied to the performance of
cifco
much is made of the income being
received by the councils three million
however the fact that sifko's each year
made significant losses is swept away as
incidental
particularly the revaluation of the
commercial properties is downplayed as a
paper loss
it doesn't matter since we're not
planning to sell the properties anytime
soon but this is the fundamental crux of
the matter is the revaluation important
is it real
now i know amongst our counselors we
have some very financially competent
people on both sides of the chamber
business people entrepreneurs people
with a background in accountancy and
some like me are farmers and all of us
are used to analyzing our businesses by
putting together a set of accounts
the central question for all of us is
around the purpose of accounting
practice
we are being told
that even though cifco is showing a
significant loss that it doesn't matter
it isn't real but accountancy is there
for a purpose a set of accounts answers
that most important question
what is the current situation where do
we stand
it sets out in black and white where we
are
left andy
so the fact that the properties were
bought are now worthless is not a paper
loss it's not wrote notional
it's real
we at the council are the bank for cifco
we are the lender i have to ask you
would any other bank lend more money on
that basis
i support the motion i suggest that all
councillors do the same thank you
thank you i'm councillor otton
thank you very much
um
we have never supported this investment
outside of the county and outside of the
district
the government as most of you know is
set to review by the end of this month
all council investments in property
and is expecting councils to use
borrowed money to be used for housing
regeneration and delivering services
in fact the chair of the government
public accounts committee
said that the increase in spend on
commercial property raises serious alarm
bells
now it has now been accepted that as a
result of coronavirus there will be a
staggering number of people becoming
unemployed
already many new people have already
registered to claim benefit who have
never done so before
so i believe it is for this council now
to invest in housing
and in delivering services
in the district
and we will then be able to support
those people and provide jobs
in the next months which will be
critical to the well-being of our
residents and the country
as a whole
now the coming recession will be unlike
any that we have ever experienced before
and we believe will be catastrophic
by investing huge amounts of money
actually in the district we have a
chance to help and do something about
that
i believe that we should support this
motion and for the council to look again
at where he wants to invest the money
and help the people of mid suffolk thank
you very much
thank you councillor whitehead
there's my camera on can you see me yes
thank you
we're in the process of building a
carefully chosen well-located and quite
diverse portfolio of commercial
properties to provide a secure long-term
income stream for our council
we're certainly not unique in doing this
councils of all political persuasions
are doing likewise
many like ourselves doing it carefully
and methodically and making full use of
external expertise
but unfortunately there are perhaps a
few others that seem to be doing it
recklessly and excessively and giving
the whole process a bad press
now we're about 70 into our civco
investment plan and every additional
asset purchased will make our portfolio
more diverse more resilient and more
balanced
we need the further income as part of
our medium term financial strategy
and to stop now would in my view
as counter member for finance be an
absolute folly we must continue this
project we must see it through to its
conclusion and create a long-term legacy
of secure income and appreciating assets
i'm fully convinced that long after many
of us would have left this council
future members in 2040 2050 and indeed
beyond will truly appreciate the legacy
we have bequeathed them
will applaud our foresight in its
creation
we already have an extensive house
building program of our own in the
pipeline and as they complete i'm sure
more will follow
that's a different capital investment
program but it is already in place
in addition there are so many already
approved private sector market sites
still awaiting development and many more
large applications presently going
through the planning process
so for all these reasons i am strongly
opposed to this motion thank you
thank you councillor richardson
thank you very much chair um i
completely agree with what councilor
gould and councillor whitehead um have
said i don't intend to go into detail
about the principles of pacifico um i
think we've discussed that many times
over the last few years council gordon
whitehead have summarized it very well
um and i may have a few comments to make
but i'll save that for the substantive
item later on the agenda
um i wanted first i think to respond to
a few of the criticisms that some of the
other counsellors um have made
or comments in general um counselor eben
i know said that uh we should pay
particular attention to the fact that
it's called the public uh works loan
board that we are uh acquiring these
loans from but i would i'm sorry that
the historian only has to point out that
both that organization and its name date
to the last 18th date to the late 18th
century and quite obviously its purpose
has evolved since then so i don't think
we should attach too much weight uh to
the language uh councilman mansell asked
how we as the conservatives can justify
um this investment decision and my
response to that would be that actually
um councils and local authorities up and
down the country have adopted this
approach to securing alternative revenue
streams from different um commercial
portfolios and if i can give you a few
examples south cambridge share district
council has an investment portfolio in
commercial property of 340 million uh
torbay council has an investment
portfolio of 300 million uh eastleigh
borough council has an investment
portfolio of 363.
million against a budget of 31 million
which is a ratio of 12 to 1 against our
ratio of three to one and the common
denominator that links all of these
councils is that they are libdem
controlled and between the three of them
they have got an investment portfolio in
excess of one billion pounds so it's not
something that is unique to the
conservatives it's a decision that has
been made by councils of all political
persuasions up and down the country um
and so
and for the avoidance of doubt this
includes investments outside of their
local authority area so we are not
unique in this i don't think we are
uniquely exposed to an
unacceptable degree of risk i think this
is a very sensible approach um so i
completely uh endorse what accounts to
gordon whitehead have said towards
councillor mellon's comments i would
just say it's important to recognize
that when he is talking about paper loss
we are in fact referring to a capital
loss that's a change that's reflected
solely in the balance sheet the report
that we've got later on in the agenda
makes very clear that there is no extra
equity required to fund that he also
referred uh to the overview and scrutiny
committee but that committee endorsed
business trading and performance report
that we have on our agenda
so whatever has happened over the last
few months i think zipko has done a
fantastic job of weathering um the storm
caused by this pandemic and it has not
impacted on our cash flow at all so i
think that is something that we should
be incredibly positive about with
regards to this particular motion i
can't support it not least because i
have severe reservations about it and
there's an enormous lack of detail i
don't see any evidence of what scoping
has been done to identify suitable land
you and whether or not that land is
already owned by the council how much it
would cost and how many houses would be
um that land would be able to
accommodate so for all of those reasons
i will not be supporting the motion
thank you chair thank you um councillor
eppinyong
can you hear me chair yes
thank you for the opportunity to speak
i'm going to keep mine brief because i
think uh councillor richardson's
councillors richardson gould and
whitehead have actually covered the
generality of some of the points i
wanted to make um
but
that said
i don't think i'll be
supporting this motion because i think
there are too many logicalities uh in
respect of it and the economic premise
on which it is based doesn't seem
terribly sound
um
cisco is actually a very successful uh
investment vehicle for the councils as
has been noted by the amounts of income
that it's generating
and to pause
the investment
at this point
you i don't think it's a viable option
as councillor passmore indicated because
we're basically saying that we don't
want to continue to generate the extra
income that that would give us and by my
calculation we are probably talking
about something in the region of a
couple of million a year
and
there is no
explanation
uh by the movers of this motion as to
actually
what we're going to do about the uh
shortfall that's going to be caused by
pausing the investment of uh that cyst
goes on and also
how we're going to um
deal with it
from from the point of view of the
council's finances so it would seem that
we we will cause ourselves a lot of
financial difficulty uh with no actual
plan of how we might get out of that and
i may add that actually we do have a
vehicle for um promoting and building
homes within the district we have the
mid subject growth limited company that
is exactly who that is exactly their
remit uh to do so and in fact um we are
working uh through our very first
project which is the redevelopment of
the uh hq in the uh needham market which
will generate
93 homes of which 10 are affordable and
just to give some sort of timeline on
that we're expecting that
the first one third of those homes
including the affordable ones will be
available to market next year and and
and mid-suffolk growth also has a plan
to deliver over 200 homes over the next
three years so i think that you know um
we are
dealing with the situation sensibly and
we are trying to protect our finances in
in a very robust and sensible way and to
come to possible
okay and to come to council pass more
point we do have a very professional
highly respected team of motivated
directors driving cisco forward and
taking all the right types of prudent
measures to make sure it is successful
so i would not be voting for this motion
thank you councillor field
thank you
i guess
[Music]
i would say that when cifco was first
proposed i obviously wondered what the
risk was
and i just think you remember looking at
the property funds that ccla runs and i
think one of the charities once as well
and observe that during the 2008 banking
crash their values went down some 20
percent or so
so one faces the possibility of
severe financial loss
uh i perhaps was pessimistic thinking
that there could be uh yet another
major depression uh so soon as the last
one
but we do know that kovid 19 is going to
drive the economy down
you know rumors are more than it's ever
gone down in the last 300 years
so we we have another severe problem
and is that the only way i judge these
things i guess i've also had a look at
the government's consultation on the use
of money from the
public works loan board
and it's clear that that conservative
government and its various financial
advisors who are probably almost as
clever as ours
are very much against this sort of
investment
uh pointing out that the board was the
finance from the board was not intended
to generate income in this way
so i personally will be voting for the
amendment
for the motion
thank you councillor humphreys
madam chair thank you um i'd like to
thank councillor gould and whitehead
really for informative and above all
factual explanation um and although like
councillor passmore i initially did have
concerns and i wasn't too happy with the
way it was going initially however
having listened to um
both the brief from council of gold and
whitehead i feel more assured now of
what's going on and also the future um
there's two green councillors um i've
already talked about that uh postbags
being full of concerns from residents
well is it just me i'm received any i
feel a little bit left out um so is it
just me and how big are your post bags
um it's a bit odd and counselor mansell
um unlike your parish um obviously we're
stone market town council i've not had
anybody at any of our council meetings
to my recall honestly those brought up
sifka and their concerns so again is it
me am i missing out um i feel a little
bit left out um so
we also have one of the counselors
mentioned online retail has gone up
that's fantastic let's get the country
going of course it has but they don't
exist in ether land they're physical
companies and they have commercial
properties that they rent and they buy
so therefore the commercial market's not
actually gone away it's still there it's
just slightly different other people
actually uh take those properties on
um council ottom you sp you talked about
the money um that should be spent on our
residence kept here well the income from
cifco supports our residents and is
spent here so it satisfies that need so
i don't understand that either um
all in all
the house building thing it's funny
isn't it when the green party often
openly
decides that they don't want to support
development that you're now looking at
building houses
you can't have your cake and eat it and
but i think it's barking mad actually
and i think that we should stick with uh
sipco for all the reasons have been
given um before this meeting and during
this meeting with the eloquent um
arguments have been given especially by
councillor gordon whitehead and i will
not be supporting this proposal
um thank you i'm councillor warboys
i'll start again
i apologize uh thank you counselor um
yeah i think this is an excellent motion
i think
we're in very very difficult times
as a country
uh we
when i first was introduced the notion
of sifka as a new council just over a
year ago
i remember
it was
surprising
to listen to the amount of optimism can
you hear me all right
yes
oh that's all right there's a lot of
squeak
the optimism surrounding these
investments um
and i was reminded of the council
investments in iceland banks which went
into serious trouble because they were
being promised huge
er returns on their investments and had
to be bailed out by the government in
this case no one's going to bail us out
it's our local taxpayers who are in fact
the lenders of
last resort has already been pointed out
in the light of the existing
situation and the economic downturns i
think it is really important that we
look at any sort of investment
strategies
to pursue the current investment
strategy that cisco proposes i think is
really foolhardy it's a bit like being
on the bridge of the titanic and carry
on at full steam ahead when someone is
saying slow down stop just look around
and see what's happening we've got covid
19 the effects of that
and we've also got a no deal brexit on
the horizon and how industry is going to
react to that
when i was told first about sifko we
were looking forward to
trade agreements across europe across
the world and things will be better than
ever
we have a 50 years commitment to these
investments it's not a case of we won't
be councils anymore but lots of us will
have left the planet we are leaving
these sort of investments to be
looked after
by
the next generation
and administrations change
there is no
financial plan for divesting itself of
any properties
we have an investment scheme that
replies upon relies upon further
investment to generate more income
i thought this was called a ponzi scheme
where income was being generated by more
and more investment the actual value of
these investments as has been admitted
it's a paper value but the value has
gone down we'll get it
it's um
diminishing returns i'm afraid
uh i think we must stop sifco's current
strategy for investment
and we must look at ways in which you
can borrow money from the public works
panel
it is public works i don't think we need
to argue about um roland
sorry can you just wrap it up you've had
your three minutes
public works is public works speculative
investment is not public works
thank you councillor wellam
thank you chair
uh
i'll be very brief um
councillor passmore referred to the
lender of last resort is our council
taxpayers and it's our residents our
council taxpayers who are telling us to
stop
and start building homes for our
residents
i feel really sorry for councillor
humphreys as no one seems to contact him
about siftko i'm contacted by
a number of people people within our
ward and people from outside the world
including stone market perhaps i'm a
more friendly person to speak to than
councillor humphreys i don't know
perhaps perhaps he ought to go out there
and ask people's opinions more
buildings have building homes provides
jobs for our residents and much of their
income would have benefit would benefit
local businesses
building market homes will provide
income and the value of their bricks and
mortar will increase year on year
and there would have been huge social
benefits for our residents as well
so
i will be voting for this motion and i
encourage all members to do so
thank you councillor morley
thank you chair
i guess a bit like um councillor
humphreys
i don't get asked about sifko
either and i've got eight parishes
to look after
um
and i i just wonder whether
the people who are
have residents who are unhappy about
cisco invent
investments
could it be because of the fake news
that's being spread
we we've heard that
we are investing in businesses outside
our district
that's fake news we are not investing in
businesses outside our district
we've also been told
about how government doesn't advocate
investing
for income again that is fake news
what the government is consulting on is
the use of the public works loan board
we've also heard that we could take all
the money that we would have been
putting into cifco and build houses
again fake news we're already building
houses
we've already built or acquired 103 over
the last two or three years
and with all the um numbers in the
pipeline
that are coming through that takes the
total up to 310
so it's not either or we can still do
both what is holding us up on building
houses
is the lack of land not the lack of
money
so
if we can put to bed all this fake news
that's going around then
perhaps our residents will feel
more encouraged and understand more
about our rationale
because our portfolio is a very
resilient portfolio
our
in fact even our scrutiny report that
we've looked at
this evening
actually says
members wanted it noted that the
committee was impressed with the work of
the cifco board and the assistant
director for assets and investments and
that is signed and authorized by
councillor wellam
clearly he's going to have a tricky
decision to make in a moment because
does he support his count his scrutiny
report or does he support this motion
thank you chair
thank you councillor brewster
thank you madam chair
um yeah we just heard from council welum
a few minutes ago that uh bricks and
mortar rise in value right the way
through the years
has he never heard of a downturn in
house prices
and
if if we are in a house which we which
we own
um
and we get a downturn in the prices do
we rush out to get them sold or you know
um we don't because we know
that hash prices over the years will
increase
this is the same with commercial
properties of course
because we've had
you you can have a downturn
um but overall over the the long period
of time we are um investing in
uh there will be risers and you know i i
hope that when we get one of those rises
that opposition members would recognize
that
um
councillor ebern also spoke about the
massive pile of money we'd assembled
over the years um
that that is true i agree
but i i've gone um aren't we happy to
have had that that money standing there
for for this rainy day that we're now
getting and that will see us through
this particular period
um
so
it's
cifco is a successful company
um
and it will be even more successful
in going forward
it's
it's it's absolutely nonsense i've been
listening to tonight about the way that
pacifico is being run down
it's not run down
but people get that perception of a
run-down company simply because it's
being broadcast
so i will certainly not be um
voting for the the um
thank you
thank you councillor geek
thank you chair um contrary to what some
councillors have implied this motion
doesn't seek to exit from sifko it
simply seeks not to extend it further so
it seeks to minimize our current risk
and this isn't folly
it's in line with the government's
current proposals now the government to
quote from their consultation document
says that a minority of local
authorities
have started using low-cost loans to buy
property primarily for rental income and
the government explained the problems in
the same way as councillor ebern has
so the treasury says
that it could expose residents to risk
the treasury says it diverts from core
services and the treasury says that it
distorts the market it makes it hard for
private businesses to compete on a level
playing field now these are the words of
the conservative
treasury department they want to stop
this activity
so i'm going to support the motion but
i'd also urge all those who agree with
the current conservative government to
do the same
thank you
um thank you councillor mayor
thank you madam chairman um i'm not
going to go over old ground that my
colleagues are so eloquently and laid
before you but i'd like to just make two
points
i joined sifko um when i became a
councillor just over a year ago
and
ever since i've been a member of cifco
i've been hugely impressed
knowledge commitment and indeed cautious
attitude that the board the executive
directors and our managing director and
chairman take to those um investments so
to say that the board doesn't have the
skills um is completely wrong um these
guest executive directors have been
operating in the property field their
whole working lives and that skill is
now being brought to bear on our
property company
and
the next point i'd like to make is about
risk
people
have
been speaking
risk has both negative and positive
positive aspects to it and we're already
seeing in cifco some of those positive
aspects coming through
the kpi for the initial yield is six
percent
our latest acquisition
resulted in a 7.94 initial yield what
does that mean
that means more bangs for our buck
we are doing well in the current market
because we are in a very strong position
we are not a public gated fund who is
having to sell property to satisfy
people um withdrawing their funds
we can take a long-term view and benefit
from them
divesting property at reduced costs
so actually at the moment cifco
has an opportunity an opportunity that
it's got to grasp to grasp it we need to
carry on with our investment strategy so
i will
not be supporting this motion and i
believe wholeheartedly in cifco as an
investment vehicle for mid-southward
council
thank you
thank you councillor carter
so yes um
i am
brought into mind a old proverb about
holding a grasping onto the tail of a
tiger
and
hearing the
opposition come back to us
um
with
what seems to be a lot of positive spin
it does seem to be like
really hoping that when cisco does
turn around and bite us on the backside
that is evil worn itself out beforehand
or that we're not around to actually be
blamed for it in the first place
uh we have
put a awful lot or
over the years we have put a lot of
positive spin into way how we perceived
it
um
and nobody likes to admit
mistakes nobody likes to admit they hold
their hands up and say they've made a
mistake
error
this
motion board
gave us opportunity of actually saying
okay maybe we didn't make a mistake but
maybe it's not right at the moment and
maybe we should look at
looking away from it
it's taking a step back and actually
securing ourselves
and all we hear is actually we've heard
back is
fake news which
he's in fake news is not the best of her
it doesn't put us in the best of the
best light and saying a green party
wishing to uh being against building
houses now wants to build houses well
social housing and for the right sort of
houses
is not the same as actually
wanting to
uh
to put in the wrong type of houses and
the
houses for the
uh
thanks for a buck but
yeah
i'd be i'm personally going to be
supporting this motion i'm
all for
being cautious and listening to
uh the consultants who have
contacted us regarding
their issues
when you get the
when you you're seen to be willing to
listen more and
less willing to talk over somebody then
you tend to be contacted by more people
i see them
um so yes
i'll be supporting this motion and uh
yeah thank you
thank you councillor pratt
sure thank you for giving me uh the
opportunity just to speak very briefly
i'm also very interested to hear in
these fake news stories i've also been
contacted by two um
of my residents um i wouldn't have
dreamt of approaching residents on on a
topic like sifko because it's not
actually quite frank in my particular
field of um direct interest i'm more
interested in climate change and
biodiversity other than um
financial property trading however it is
it is quite a keen topic for many of my
residents
um
and and they are
um conservative voters at heart as well
i must add um fake news have we been
reading the east anglian daily times the
financial times the guardian are we
listening to
why the government is so roundly
critical of these kinds of investments
by these councils can we really just
blame it
on a small minority of councils that are
doing this no it's not us it's the
others not being diligent in their in
enough in their investments they've
given us all bad rap i'm not sure if i
buy into that to be quite to be quite
frank um
what is the future of commercial
properties in town centers
okay i know we're not just invested in
that but many of our but many of our
properties are what is the future we
don't know they might not be
uh entirely profitable um
now it's it's also likely that the
government
um in denouncing and condemning
um these investments are likely to
forbid them in the future so what is our
what is our um
root for for divestment
what's really important about this
motion is that it's asking it's it's
it's telling us to pause
the investments it's not telling us to
to die to sell those properties off
um i would also like to know what is the
promise that capital value will rise i
think wishful thinking
could lead um many uh
people
into into bankruptcy especially those
who are borrowing money in order to to
make these investments i think wishful
thinking sets a very dangerous precedent
for the future of our district council
and its services therefore i will be
voting for this motion
thank you
um thanks at the moment we've got no
more hands but before we we do anything
else um we're gonna have to extend the
meeting as it's um it's going up for
three hours and i'll need a proposer and
a seconder to um to extend the meeting
so have i got a proposal
uh yes madam chair i'm happy to propose
the extended meeting thank you
madam chair i'd like to second that
proposal thank you thanks very much so
we will go back to um is there any
sorry we need to vote is there anyone
that doesn't want to do this because
then can you put your hand up
so i'm going to give you like five more
seconds is there anyone that doesn't
want to extend the meeting
okay so that's like that's a no and
we're gonna go on so um at the moment
i've got no more hands and so if if
there's no one else then i'll go back to
andrew and rachel to speak
thank you thank you chair uh yeah that
was that was interesting uh didn't
expect to be accused of fake news and
i'm sure those people that have
contacted us with their very legitimate
concerns we will obviously now express
them to those that are claiming they're
ill founded uh i want to start my little
speech with a quote uh and the quote is
that we have been elected we have been
elected to be the decision makers and
that was a direct quote from our leader
of our council last week it's not focus
groups that make the decisions here or
consultants we are the decision makers
and 50 percent of this house and the
majority of the electorate when last
asked would like msdc to move away from
borrowing to speculate outside of our
own patch
so what can we do do we keep doing the
same thing and expecting a different
result
because that's the definition of
insanity so let's look back at what we
could have done
had we reinvested the sifko millions in
delivering
some of the 8 000 plus houses that we've
already got approved and not built in
mid-suffolk we would have realized over
2 million pounds a year in rent at
affordable rent tenure level had we have
used a strict commercial
rent that would have been 2.4 million a
year we would have received a third of a
million pounds a year in council tax
uh we would also average 450 000 pounds
a year in new homes bonus that figure
alone on its own would have covered all
of the costs of borrowing with money to
spare
for niceties like building our homes
using local workers to an exemplary
environmental standard
and the homes on our books would have
increased in value over this time by
around 10 million pounds
that's that's not a paper loss that's a
paper game
and had we built these homes we would
have not have lost our five-year land
supply for all those years
but of course you decided not to take
this path and many of you were those
very decision makers back in 2016 msdc
had 10 million in reserves today we have
17.7 million so we did not need to risk
all of this borrowing we've basically
tried to solve a problem we never had
so let's get back to today we can move
away and start to make that step away
from the count out of county investments
and investing more right here right now
the great irony is this week alone we
made the latest inquisition 48 hours ago
great to hear it's a great success but
the great irony this week we in we
rushed around to invest in a in a
building that has health provision while
one of our own cifco directors lives
next door to his nearest surgery has had
to close because it needs investment and
this is so ironic um so today we that
i'm now wrapping up we the decision
makers and this house is completely
balanced so basically the chance to take
a different direction is on the
shoulders of every single one of us that
doesn't mean we'll immediately settle
current investments that we would
commercial that would be commercial
suicide but moving across to local
housing investment would and disposing
of current assets most appropriate time
is all we ask so today be that decision
maker back this motion and deliver from
in suffolk
thank you
thank you very much chair um firstly i'd
like to say thank you very much to
everybody for your contributions um to
this debate um and particularly those of
you across the all political parties who
have really dealt with this emotion um
sensibly and um
and well thought out in your comments
um
and just to confirm this isn't personal
and
you know the advisors and the
consultants and the employees at
mid-suffolk that work on this they they
do the job they're employed to do and
i'm sure they do that very well and very
professionally
um
i was referring to it's the council the
council's decision our decision that
matters in this regard
and
i am a bit disappointed about um
people invoking
the words of the u.s president because i
really don't think that kind of language
is helpful in in a political um in our
own chamber in in mid-suffolk and that
using that kind of language just is not
really helpful
just to put right to some of the
comments as well um i also don't think
it's helpful when councillors
wrap up baber and mid-suffolk's
finances together
so for example somebody referred to
three million across the councils
and unless you'd listened to the yes you
wouldn't you might not heard it people
might go away thinking oh it's mid
suffolk they've been three million it's
not it's mid suffolk and baby
and that's over the past few years and
again wrapping up several years
just to make you know the figures sound
bigger we really need to be careful of
that and really need to be clear to to
all our constituents
and i think as android said you know
somebody else refer to much needed
income but we've got seven million
pounds more now than we had four years
ago you know and yes john whitehead has
you know that's he's been the cabinet
member for finance during that time but
it doesn't take away from the fact that
we have got seven million pounds more
than we had and so i don't think any
constituent of yours or any resident
would think that that that we need
sifko's providing much needed income
because with those figures you know it
isn't given we've got a budget of 10
million
and the last little point is just you
know if we're not investing in business
then i'm not really quite sure who we're
buying these properties from because
surely somebody owns them and we and we
pay for them somehow and they're bought
um so i think we just need to be a bit
clear about some other language
but to really to wrap up again i would
like to say thank you ever so much to
everybody for your contributions i think
it's been a really fantastic debate and
i only wish we could be there in person
because it'd be so good to actually be
able to kind of talk to everybody in
person and i'm really not enjoying kind
of this lockdown mode and i would love
to be in the council chamber with
everybody um debating but it's been a
very good debate and
i am really pleased as i say with a lot
of the um comments that people have made
and that people have taken it seriously
and really thought about it because i
think that's one thing we can do
everyone's got the opportunity to really
think about this hard and to be able to
support this this motion
with me and i really appreciate it thank
you very much
right thank you i will now ask the
corporate manager for governance and
civic officer office to take a vote
thank you chair if members could please
reply with for against or abstain
counsellor amma wrong and morrison
councillor brewster
against
cancer burn
sorry
sorry we'll go back to you sorry
counselor would you like to respond
yes american uh
four
four cancer brewster
against
councillor byrne
councillor carter
four
councillor castin
against councillor
flatman
against
councillor fleming against councillor
geek
four
councillor gould
against
cancer guthrie
councillor hattingham against
councillor hicks against
councillor humphreys
against
councillor mansell for
councillor madison
or
councilmelon
four
councillor mayor
against councillor morley
against councilman muller against
councillor norris
four
councillor otton
councillor
against
richardson against cancer scarf four
council stringer
four
cancer turner four
councillor war boys
four
councillor welum
councillor whitehead
against
chair that is uh um
17 17.
so that do you want to exercise your
casting boat i don't need tj
i didn't need to do i
so it's
anyway so um so that has failed
sorry
it's only failed if you use your casting
vote surely lavinia it's 17 against 17.
i thought if it was if you hadn't won
you hadn't it failed chair if i can come
in at this point please
uh thank you uh councillors we have a
tied vote at 17 17 so the chairman can
now choose whether or not she wishes to
use her casting vote um she can vote in
any manner she wishes um
and if she chooses not to use the
casting vote the motion will fall
thank you chair
i won't choose my casting vote and the
motion will fall
so moving on to the next um
[Music]
to the next
item which is um
it's quite his 16 but i don't believe
that's the right number
sorry sorry sorry where are we
all right here we go um
no that's
[Music]
all right sorry
item number 17
mc-1951 capital investment fund company
sifco capital limited business trading
and performance report 2019-2020
i would like to welcome christopher
hayworth chair of sifco capital limited
mark sargentson sifco director henry
cook cipro sifco director and neville
pritchard director capital marx jones
lang lasalle
councillors i'd like to deal with this
item in the open part of the gender if
possible so can i please ask members to
refrain from asking any questions that
relate to individual tenants and
associated risks
if you wish to ask questions on these
elements please can you indicate and we
will move into the closed session at
that point before returning to the open
session to vote on both recommendations
in the report
i would like to invite councillor google
to introduce paper this emcee
19 51 and to move the recommendations in
the report
thank you very much
um
yes i'm conscious that
some of the
issues
behind civco been pretty well rehearsed
uh
in in the last half an hour or so but
this is the business plan and uh
i'm pleased to uh
support this report which details uh
cifco's capital's performance capital
performance over the last 12 months
and the proposed business plan for the
next 12 months
the the business plan is a fundamental
part of cifco's governance and ensures
accountability to its shareholders
cifco's provided the councils
with approximately three million of net
income since its inception in 2017.
approximately 1.6 million was received
in the last financial year equating to
approximately 10 percent of the
council's workforce costs
or if you like 13.5
of council tax
income this income is essential in
enabling the councils to continue to
invest and deliver services within our
district
cifco forms only part of the council's
investment with funds also been invested
in the delivery of new market and social
homes and employment opportunities
across the district
the council is due to start on site with
the development of approximately 180
homes over the next 12 months as well as
investing in the delivery of
156 acres
employment scheme in stone market and in
supporting our larger towns to adapt and
thrive in the future
no investment is without risk however
the professional strategic approach
adopted by cifco in investing in
managing these funds for an income
return has demonstrated the resilience
of the portfolio even in these developed
covert
times
in fact cifco collected over 75
of the march quarter rent
and to date suspected over 65
of the june quarter rent uh and
constantly
consequently has been able uh to make
the full debt repayment uh to the
council in march and june while
difficult times remain ahead with the
continued impact of covid the proposed
business plan seeks to continue the
investment of the second toronto funds
approved by the council last year and in
doing so to further diversify the
portfolio away from high street retail
focusing on industrial and alternative
sectors and to continue to
deliver and grow this important revenue
stream for the councils and create a
long-term legacy for the councils for
the council uh as as um and the chairman
has said uh we're fortunate in having
with us uh this evening uh our
professional uh advisors and uh civco uh
non-executive directors uh to uh
help us in our discussion and to answer
questions that colleagues may have thank
you
um thank you can i have a second
yes madam chairman i'm happy to second
the motion
thank you councillor mayor
um so we will now move into questions
and debate counselors may ask as many
questions as they wish however they must
be relevant to the subject under
discussion and must be a question when
we get to the debate element counsellors
will only be allowed to speak once for
three minutes and this will be timed
um
councillor mansell
uh thank you thank you chair um i would
just like to ask if these two uh
recommendations uh 3.1 and 3.2
can be taken as two separate votes
yes
i don't see it
um counselor guthrie
sorry i beg your pardon i've been
pressing the wrong buttons again i'm
sorry
council guthrie there
i am and i said i beg your pardon i
pressed the wrong button i was trying to
mute my microphone sorry
can you hear me yeah
well i don't wish to speak i put i put
my head up in the accident
sorry
um counselor matheson
thank you chair um
i'd i'd like to ask um
bearing in mind that the the councillors
our council was put in
uh equity
into cifco of three million pounds uh in
addition to baber also putting in three
million pounds um i wondered if um
somebody um
amongst our board members
can um tell us what sort of
um value our equity has now
um and what they think that will be
the 31st of march 2020
after having addressed post balance
sheet events which the auditors will
need to do
thank you
uh
emily haytak is able to help
thank you councillor um so the uh equity
value um in relation to the properties
so the properties acquired on the basis
of 10 equity and 90 loan
so the valuation is value sorry the
portfolio is valued as a whole and so
the value of the portfolio currently uh
represents 90 debt and 10 equity so the
equity um is 10 to the the value of the
the portfolio as a whole and each
council holds five percent of the um
equity uh in the company
does that help to address your question
uh
not not very much really the um
the question was you know what is our
equity worth now
um
post post the 31st of march and taking
into account account post balance sheet
events
covid really
um and um
also i think if if you
look at on that basis of 90 loan 10
equity
then if that raises a further question
of whether the
loans the value of the properties
will support the loans that we have
outstanding
so
excuse me sorry so in terms of your
question um relating to valuation the
portfolio was uh revalued on the 31st of
march
2020 so that was after lockdown had
occurred and so the evaluation figures
do
reflect the uncertainty
in the market at that point in time in
relation to covid
and the the pandemic
um in relation to the
um the capital and loan uh query uh so
the capital um and loan borrowed
reflects the uh acquisition costs and
also the costs of acquisition so the um
stamped gtm fees incurred so at this
point in time and the cost or capital
expended is greater than the portfolio
value
okay thank you i'll have to write that
down and think about it
okay um
we've got several more hands up but i'm
just going to ask for a quick break for
a comfort break so um let's get back
together at um in four minutes which is
at 8 45. okay thanks
i can't turn any of my stuff off
okay guys we're back on and um the first
question is from andrew mellon or the
next question sorry
uh thank you chair and can i just
virtually say how grateful i was for
that comfort break
now this is really just a clarification
on the answer that emily gave i don't
know if she can answer or one of our
advisors
given the previous answer on the equity
that the council has put in okay
are the properties worth more or less
than the outstanding loans
given that the loans are still
outstanding
has that equity in effect disappeared
and on in the basis of a strict funds
flow
has the council received more
from cifco than it has put in
strictly on funds flow
and so in terms of the
as i mentioned before we have the cost
of acquisition uh that are part of the
capital borrowed so that includes
approximately three and a half million
pounds in stamp duties and fees and so
the portfolio as stated within the
portfolio of value as stated within the
report is in the order of 52 million
and we have incurred costs of
acquisition of around three and a half
million um and a reduction in value of
the assets
of approximately eight
across the the last two years which
equates to around 4.7 million and so
in effect the value of the portfolio is
less than the
um value of the
debt incurred however the portfolio does
continue to generate an income
which does
um
enable it does repay back that
debt in effect so even in the face of
the challenges we've had with kovid 19
the income
from the rental properties has been
sufficient to continue to pay that debt
and in terms of the council's debt
position and the
across both councils the uh debt equates
to approximately 25 percent of the rent
roll um received from cis from cifco
and in respect of the uh just mid
suffolk it's in the order of 29 so
there's approximately
three times um cover in terms of the uh
cash or flow through to um
the the council the council over the
last um three years since inception
has benefited from over four million
pounds worth of repayments um to the
uh to the council both in terms of
interest and and capital and cifco
itself has benefited from just under
five and a half million pounds
does that help to answer your question
uh you there's two questions that you
haven't answered
one is the position of the equity
and the second one is in terms of funds
flow that is income to the council
compared to equity gone in what is the
position positive or negative
sorry apologies my systems struggling
and so in terms of um
so in terms of sorry your query in
relation to the
position with the equity sorry yeah
so would you okay let me put it in
another way
the equity that we've put in
i would ask is that more or less than
the income we've received and it has
that equity disappeared in effect uh the
current
trading situation
so the equity hasn't disappeared but it
has reduced and because it is um a
percentage of the property value in
effect
so um the
equity has seen the same impact on value
as the portfolio as a whole so the
portfolio as a whole is reducing value
by approximately eight percent and so
has the um the equity element
so that would affect me that the equity
has gone down by 80 percent so 10 down
to 2
we've lost 80 percent of the equity
um i haven't looked at the figures in
that in that way so i'd need to have a
look at the figures in a percentage term
but i'm happy to look at that outside
the meeting
well can come one of the other advisors
give us a
a real answer
because i think councils really need to
know
is there a net going to the council and
i don't believe there is
so
just in terms of that um
point so um in terms of the um cash flow
into the council the councils have
benefited from over four million pounds
of debt repayment
and so uh that um if we look at the
income that zifko has received over the
period investment that's in in the order
of five and a half million pounds um
versus a debt reduction
sorry a reduction in the port valley
portfolio value of 4.7 million
so um if you look at that um portfolio
value reduction against the repayments
that the councils have received of 4.2
million can see that and there is um
some
um
quite close correlation between those
those amounts
so the the net income to the council
that which has been trumpeted in the
report actually
is pretty much
no that's not
we've got in as much money in equity as
we've gained out of it in income
so the this fund was always set up as an
income fund so we're looking at um the
equity element is the capital element
that equity hasn't disappeared and
the councils still benefit from a 10
percent um
stake in in the properties and as has
been said um in the reports um and
throughout the meeting tonight and the
values of properties um do fluctuate in
line with the market both up and
downwards and as such and that equity
hasn't disappeared it's just the value
of that equity at this point in time um
is 8 less than it was previously and
henry cook has just come on screen he's
one of the directors of cifco and has a
particular expertise in finance and so
i'll pass over to henry
so yeah
it's henry cook here i just i i think to
ask you a question has the equity value
been wiped out no it hasn't is it a lot
lower than it
was originally absolutely because we've
seen a big reduction in the value of the
portfolio
largely as well to covered but also as a
result of the cost of acquisitions so
every time you buy a property
you're about six percent in costs that
you incur so you effectively you
immediately buy a commercial property
you lose six percent in costs that are
not recoverable but you do that you get
a decent return out of the portfolio but
that return is a long-term annuity
stream so it's not a one-off income so
but we have had a one-off
income loss as a result of the cost of
the acquisition and then devaluation of
the properties have they wiped out the
equity no they have not are they close
to doing it potentially probably
but that kovid
markdown is a temporary market thing if
you for example instead of buying
commercial property we'd invested in
what's a risk-free investment uk
government bonds we bought 30-year gifts
at the same time we would have actually
taken a 20 hit to the valuation of that
portfolio at a time when cifco actually
took about a 7 valuation
what's interesting about that is that
you think that uk government bonds are
no risky but you've taken a twenty
percent hit which is much bigger than we
took on the
civco portfolio
but what returns we've got if we'd
invested in those uk government bonds we
would have got not six percent
but six tenths of one percent in terms
of return
so
what's interesting to me is that
although the cisco portfolio has taken a
valuation hit
relative return it generates that
hit is really really low
and we could have invested something
everybody else would have said is much
safer but in fact
our return would have been so much lower
if we'd done that that would wipe out
all our potential um they get the loss
would have wiped out all our potential
gains for the next 20 years whereas here
we've taken a bit of a hit but it's a
paper hit
we expect that valuation to improve over
time as
things recover and the market returns to
normal can i tell you how long that's
going to take absolutely not do i think
this is a massive
market impact yeah absolutely but what
is it really encouraging to me is
actually the amount that that portfolio
has taken in terms of the devaluation
results as a result of code is
relatively low we're still generating a
big chunk of our income i was really
pleasantly surprised
given the impact this has had on the
economy how much of our rent we actually
collected we've actually outperformed
other portfolios in terms of our rent
collection if you look at the industry
average it's and and and jones language
we've done this it's below where our
apollo is why is that it's because we've
diversified our portfolio we diversified
in terms of
uh
the
type of
tenant that we have we diversified it
also
geographically and
in the types of property and it's that
diversification which is really key to
ensuring that this becomes a stable
income generator in the future
yes we will have capital fluctuations
but in the same way everybody says
residential property is goes up in in
price well it doesn't 1988 in the uk we
saw
residential property in the uk decline
by 30 percent
what was this first reason to recover
after that in 1998 east anglia
it took eight nine years for east anglia
to recover the rest of the uk recovered
much faster and that's why diversifying
your investment away from a single
region is also a risk mitigant and
really has certainly had his portfolios
performed so absolutely if we taken a
hit yeah have we taken as a hit as bad
as everybody else no
and is our income that we're generating
in perpetuity
strong relative to the hits we're taking
absolutely
thank you for that um so i'm moving on
to councillor ebern
thank you very much chair um
i've got um three well two questions
really but firstly can i just have a
plea again to um counsellors when they
are um
and in general on this um
business this is mid-suffolk district
council's meeting not babers and not a
joint one so please when we're kind of
introducing or discussing papers can we
please just have the mid-suffolk figures
not joint figures um because we really
should be just discussing our own
business and not um not babes as well um
so my first question is is to
make sure we have that please
secondly two questions i've got one
is just with regards to the admin cost
um
which
i understand is 545 000 it says in the
report but i presume that's across both
councils um i'd just like to know what
the largest amount is
what's the biggest
um
thing that makes up that sum please um
and then second question is um
there's been a certain amount of
investment that's happened in the last
kind of few years
so have this hap i'd just like to know
how have the strategies
changed with regard to the remainder
that's due to be invested thank you very
much chair
thank you councillor
and so in relation to the um
administration costs and the largest
costs are the professional advice that
we obtain in terms of managing the
portfolio and so that's the the largest
element of um costs so that's our third
party advisors and in relation to the um
strategy and i'd like to invite um the
chair chris howarth to um respond to to
that question um
if chris could come forward
yes i think hopefully i'm now turned on
so you can uh you can see me um yes i
mean that i suppose one of the whole
points about
revising the business plan each year is
because we have to uh keep our strategy
that um suits the market as it is one of
the things that has happened over the
last three years has been pointed out by
a number of councillors is that the um
the retail market has changed enormously
high street retail um is an area where
people far fewer people are shopping in
the high street many more people are
shopping online and that has hit the
high street hard there have been a
number of councils and this has been
something which has rather confused the
argument over um the public works loan
board for instance but a number of
councils have invested in shopping
centers in their area for regeneration
now that's a very very highly risky
strategy to take forward because
regeneration of a retail you know the
shopping center in east these times is
very very difficult indeed um
that that's not obviously what we've
been doing at cifco um but as part of
the the high street um having suffering
very difficult times people shopping
more
the uh the industrial market the
warehouse market has been very very
strong um and there's good demand there
so
at every board meeting we look at we're
looking at the market we're lucky enough
to have um our advisors jones lang who
are there to advise us what's happening
in the market and perhaps we can hand
over to them in a minute um but we do
revise our strategy all the time the
fact that we've now got the kovit 19 and
the pandemic over the last few months
has made it very very important to real
focus on the quality of the income the
strength of the tenant the longevity of
the income and the particular sectors
that we might be looking at the um
you know the food and beverage sector
has been having a very hard time because
of the pandemic the retail sector things
have been made worse there as well so
yes we absolutely revise our strategy at
every meeting looking to see where we
think the best opportunities to develop
one of the things about the pandemic is
that there are some interesting
opportunities to look at um and we will
continue to look at those
i i don't know whether the level from
jones lang would like to come in really
and say anything at this point
yes good evening everybody
um
as chris says we do regularly revisit
the strategy going forwards and one of
the things which has become clear is
that diversity is key
uh high street retail only comprises
about 15 of the portfolio so a lot of
the portfolio is diverse in the likes of
warehousing and offices and other
commercial sectors so it has held up
comparatively well despite the difficult
times we've been in as far as any
changes are concerned
what we are
or what the way we've addressed things
recently is is very much to
emphasize the tenant quality um and the
income security and the average lease
and expired is about eight and a half
years across the whole portfolio
which is quite a long
contractual income commitment
which
will see the rent coming in over that
period
and
looking forward
then we are trying to diversify
not to have too large a lot size not to
have too much
investment in one particular location
one particular tenant one particular
style of property
and that has held up comparatively well
over the course of the last
six months when we found things have
been tricky
but certainly
what the march rent collection was
particularly tricky um june rent
collections uh have improved partly i
think because occupiers can see some
light at the end of the tunnel
thank you
um we will now move on to i'm councillor
morrison
holly are you there i am here hello
thank you hi sure um
so
for the benefit of those who might be
watching
who
haven't got a business degree
um i wonder if it's possible for you to
answer in this way
um
when
is it possible to forecast
when sifko as an enterprise
might break even at what point in the
future
um
that his forecast please
thank you um so
i mentioned in um the paper that there
are costs of acquisition
um and we we talked about this earlier
so the costs of the property acquisition
tend to be in the region of six seven
percent um and as such it's anticipated
that until we complete the investment
period um we will continue to um
have impairments in relation to these
additional costs so the costs of
acquisition of the portfolio to date
have been in the order of at three and a
half million and based on six and three
quarter percent and 100 million
investment we'd expect those total costs
to be in the order of uh
6.75 million
and as such
we would expect that break even will
occur once the fund has been fully
invested
and the um point just to note here is
obviously um the
impact of the market on on that in terms
of uh the sort of capital valuation um
uh
perspective so that's an area that we're
unable to forecast forward in terms of
property values
so so we're unable to predict the um
break even can you give me a ballpark
year 2030.
so
so as i've mentioned we're we're
anticipating that after full investment
and that the
impairments will
will be completed in effect but what i
can't do is predict the value of the um
portfolio
ahead of time so i'm a member of the
rics and that's
the royal institution of childhood
surveyors and we are um directed not to
predict values forward because the
market isn't something that you can
forward predict but what i am saying is
that we would expect that once full
investment has completed
the market stabilizes that's a point
where the capital losses and will be
curtailed and when does investment
period
so the the investment period and within
the business plan is proposed to be
completed by october
next year so that's the intended
investment period obviously there will
be impairments within that financial
year
so i would expect impairments to
continue until uh the end of march uh
21.
can i can i just come in there i mean
it's it's important really you're
talking about breaking even i think
you're probably talking about breaking
even in capital terms um and and as
emily quite rightly says it's impossible
to predict that um in income terms
obviously um
in income term then it is doing very
much more than breaking even at the
moment which is why there's been um a
net return to the council um over the
period that cifco has been trading um so
in other words the the profit if you
like what to call it that over and above
i mean the income over and above the
debt repayments has given
and i'm sorry to cut for this to council
reuben i don't know the individual
figures but you know it's given three
million pounds of net income to the
councils with that
yeah okay but that's not
including the expenditure and the well
the um the debts right now no because
that one has to be you've got to be
quite rigorous in keeping the capital
side and the um
the income side separate what you're
talking about is the capital side um and
as emily has quite rightly said at the
moment um we don't know when um that
will uh break even because there have
been significant um costs of acquisition
as i've already said and there's been
some right down in value
but can you give me some kind of range
of possibility
i really don't think it's possible to
to say i mean as emily has rightly said
when we have completed the acquisition
program then we won't have any further
acquisition costs um that will so that
will improve the situation as far as
when the value of the properties go up
then
as the uncertainty of the um the
pandemic come
disappears which we hope it will um then
the there will be uh valuations will
increase
um
if we're able to
um get longer leases on some of our
properties that will also bring about um
increases in valuation there are lots of
things it really is impossible to say
we think in three years time or six
years time or whatever that we think
that the value will be more than the
cost if you like
looking at it purely in capital terms
yeah okay so we can't we can't say to
constituents right now we can't really
predict the future my lovely boy so i
think we're going to have to move on
from this
uh that's very patronizing i don't
appreciate that i'm sorry but you know
we need to move on
councillor scarf
thank you chair yeah um at the scrutiny
committee we heard um of the amount of
rent collected the amount of rent that
was going on a payment plan and the
amount of rent that was deferred um
i made the comment at the committee that
uh how certain were we about collecting
those deferrals bearing in mind that the
economic situation
is changing daily
and many companies even
real blue chip companies are in great
difficulty i wonder can you give me any
information about the length of time
that you've agreed for deferrals by the
tenants in order to pay what they owe
and secondly how certain are you about
the likelihood of collecting those
deferrals from the tenants bearing in
mind the economic situation at the
moment
thank you
that's a question to one of the sifko
people please uh chair
um i think sorry coming in there emily
may have some better figures as to what
we
we have agreed with um the tenants but i
think the maximum is up to about uh two
years um
we are
as confident as we can be that we will
collect those
those funds um they are obviously held
under lease they're under a contractual
obligation to to pay the rent um now
there is a possibility that some tenants
may go bust of course that happens with
um any um property portfolio um so
really i mean i can't give any more
further information than that i don't
know emily whether you have any
more detailed information
um so there is some detail um within the
report um which sets out the um
the
uh
type of um arrangements that we have put
in place i think it's at paragraph 10.5
and so it shows that approximately
eleven and a half percent
of the income has been um deferred in
terms of a monthly payment plan so what
that means is rather than um rent being
paid quarterly in advance which is the
more typical
collection rate
those tenants are actually paying their
rent on a monthly basis and as such we
will be collecting and by the end of the
quarter a further 11 and a half percent
in effect
the table also um then sets out um
approximately four percent in terms of
uh deferrals and those deferrals have
been agreed on a an individual um basis
depending on
those individual um tenant uh businesses
and the impact of covered upon those
upon those businesses and as chris said
some of those have been on a much
shorter term some on a much longer term
and with the longer term being that sort
of two-year bracket
um and and again as chris mentioned you
know we are in a period of economic
uncertainty and we are um aware that
some of our tenants may not um may not
survive the crisis but again you'll see
from that table and that that's a much
smaller element um
than of the portfolio as a whole
i think it's also important to say at
this stage i mean
in the
in times past there's been very much
rather sort of adversarial um tenant
landlord relationship but as a
professional landlord nowadays it's very
much a matter of working with one's
tenants and so therefore you know when
we've had a if a tenant has come to us
we think genuinely that you know
their business which is hardship then we
work with them to make sure that that
business survives and that's that is
what the the modern uh professional
landlord tenant relationship is it's
very much a partnership
thank you
for example just to go on that chris
sorry to interrupt it um some of our
tenants have come to us and said yeah we
want hardship and we said
your business is functioning perfectly
you're earning the income
no you need to continue paying
others we said yeah we can see that you
haven't got the money to pay us so let's
work it out
some of those ultimately may not pay us
but they're going to be a small
percentage
[Music]
cats and we are on mute i'm afraid so we
can't hear you
is having problems coming off moot at
the moment so um she'll be with you as
soon as possible
[Music]
come on my lovely girl
um councillor hanningham is having
technical difficulties so if we could go
to councillor morning x please thank you
thank you thank you chair um i just
wonder welcome
sir christopher and
henry and neville welcome to our council
chamber i wonder if you could just say a
little bit about your your backgrounds
um and also
in 10.9
where you say the the board has
considered the merits of acquiring 77
assets
and have actually acquired two that that
sounds like a hell of a lot of due
diligence has gone in there i wonder if
you could just say a little bit about
the process that you go through
for um
ending up with two out of 77.
sorry emily
can i butt in
we're really wanting to sort of um close
this um you know finish up in in at 9
45. and so um i understand what you're
trying to say but um but if we could try
and sort of move this on we haven't even
got into the debate yet
do you not think it's worth
hearing the process that our directors
go through in selecting two out of 77
assets well i mean i can if i can answer
that very quickly i think i mean just my
background is i'm a fellow of the royal
institution child affairs i've been
involved in property all my life um as
far as the um
the process is concerned i mean most of
the opportunities we look at comes come
through jones lang they look at probably
five or six hundred properties a year
before they and out of which they may
decide that there are 70 which we might
like to consider as a board we look at
we we do have a considerable property
expertise on the board uh commercial
expertise so we look at assets and we
think we i think you'll find that we bid
on
uh 17 i think out of which we acquired
two and the reason for that is that if
we you know if we we can look at a
problem yes we like that we'll bid on it
um but if it gets to the stage where
somebody is going to bid more than we
think it's worth then before then we
drop out we don't we don't just carry on
and try and acquire it so it is
it is a it's a process which works very
well um and i think the fact that we've
only acquired two it's been it's been a
challenging year from that point of view
and we had had only acquired two during
the course of that year
because the due diligence is
considerable in in all aspects of the
properties that we're looking at
thank you
i'm so moving on to councillor wellam
keith
mute
yeah i'm the think i'm there thank you
very much um could i ask why is the time
scale for just discussing this business
plan
fixed such that we are debating it just
a few days before the annual accounts
for 2019 2020 are available
would it not have appeared more open and
transparent to have had this debate when
up-to-date information is available
rather than relying on accounts that are
12 months out of date
that's one question the second question
is
that following my request at scrutiny
i'd hoped that we would have seen in the
business plan a reduction or divestment
strategy
why do you not include a strategy for
sales of assets
so um if i can just address that
question in relation to the accounts the
business plan um is using the
information from the um accounts uh for
the year end 1920 so that information is
within the the business plan um and um
reflects the the the position this year
uh cifco is a trading company
uh needs to publish its uh trading
accounts
with companies housed by the end of the
year and we always try to publish them
more quickly than that um in order to be
as transparent as as we're able to be
and also so that the company accounts
can be consolidated into the council's
own accounts and so it's to fit in with
a council's um time scale but certainly
that accounting information
is used very much in terms of the
production of the um business plan on an
annual basis
um in terms of your um other question um
in relation to um
an exit strategy or divesting and the
the assets um
the shareholders have
sought us to invest and build a
portfolio we haven't
been
directed by the shareholders to look at
divestment
um
indeed in terms of the
capital losses potentially any sales at
this point in time
would look at realizing those losses as
opposed to holding those assets until
the market is in better condition and i
don't know whether chris wants to add
anything further in that regard
yes i i will i mean the the board really
has two very important roles first of
all obvious it's the acquisition which
we've been talking about but having
acquired the portfolio then it's a
matter of managing that portfolio
maximizing the the value of it
particularly in terms of the rents
coming in and that's something which
goes on all the time but as part of that
when you when one is looking at an asset
and the rents are going up and you're
perhaps you then negotiate a longer
lease what you have is a is a value
curve of an of an asset and it is
certainly true to say that we will
be looking as the portfolio moves
forward and we may consider we've added
as much value as we think we can to this
asset now would be a good time to sell
it and reinvest in something where we
can add value again so that is that is
something which we we do now i think
it's probably too early for for
the portfolio i think stand um but it is
certainly something that we do all the
time
so we're just going to move on to the
last two questions from councillor
stringer and councillor pratt so cancer
stringer
thank you chick um yeah a couple of
questions uh in the original strategy
documents we were only investing in
sites that could easily be changed in
planning terms if things did get sticky
and difficult i just want to make sure
and confirm
with that's the acquisitions we're still
making
uh
you were suggesting that rental income
was tricky this march
but of course this march we had
the prospect of government furloughing
people business rate freezes business
rate grants
uh and
the the eventual deal of the eu still
another nine months away do you forecast
that the end of furloughing or the
phasing out following the end of the
one-off business rate and business rate
freeze is coming along and the actual
deal of the eu is going to make
the end of the year harder to get the
rent than march
uh and one other little bit about risk
radar uh glad to see in your in the
document it says you're going to be
working with tenants to see if you can
help move to a decarbonized economy
but in the housing sector the government
put the onus of bringing
development up to spec onto the landlord
and have we got that risk on our radar
that that the government makes
commercial landlords bring their
buildings up to a 21st century spec
uh should i perhaps answer the uh the
first question in terms of the um
underlying value and whether one can get
planning for alternative uses that's
absolutely a part of the due diligence
we go through looking at any asset we
look to see what if everything goes
completely wrong and we need to change
the um the use of the of the asset
that's certainly a part of the due
diligence and will continue to be so
um
and in in terms of the um
from a market perspective whether it may
be more challenging later in the year
than um in march um we are currently
going through a world pandemic there
isn't a blueprint for this we don't have
a a model that we can look back on and
and say you know this is what happened
um in a previous uh occasion so it's
very difficult to predict um what the
market is going to look like um in that
regard um i do wonder whether neville
pritchard from jones lang would like to
to comment um
in that regard um in terms of his
experience in the um sort of
international property market and and
the view that that's been taken there
yes i mean
clearly there are some difficult times
coming and some businesses will find it
tough with
as you say a number of um costs
which have been offset through furlough
schemes etc essentially coming back on
stream and there will be more
unemployment we know that
and times will be more difficult for a
number of occupiers but that's precisely
why when we're selecting investments we
look at assets which are
good quality they're assets which are
left to strong tenants as opposed to
tenants who are likely to fall at the
first hurdle
and
situations where
if the worst does happen they should
prove relatable relatively easily
at similar sort of rent to the ones
which have been previously achieved as
opposed to looking at assets which have
a artificially high rent which could
never be achieved again if the tan
failed
it's difficult to see which way the
economy is going and we've heard that
u-shaped and v-shaped and l-shaped and
all sorts of uh different sorts of
recoveries we're not sure how long it's
going to be but it always does come back
i've been doing this for 33 years now
and
commercial property does bounce back
well over the last
years and 15 years properties out formed
guilts and equities
the beauty of property is that it's a
physical asset it is something which has
a purpose it has an intrinsic value in
itself as opposed to a paper value
so fundamentally
our selection policy is very much driven
towards being risk-averse
and like i said earlier we have
long-term leases to strong tenants
as far as we're able to
find those sort of assets for you
and in terms of the selection policy we
talked earlier about how many assets we
look at with a view to how many of those
are actually bought and that degree of
selection is very much driven to making
it as
risk averse as possible
thank you councillor pratt you'll ask
this be the last question
daniel you've disappeared do you want to
ask a question or not
yes indeed i do sorry about that i
didn't unmute and i will keep it very
brief um just to
clarify
and for my own understanding
despite a lot despite the liability of
assets and the acquisition costs from
what i gather you're saying that we're
in positive equity and because of this
positive equity we are able to receive
an income
from the investment
um you may have already have have sort
of
shed some light on this but it may have
gone over my head um
the
covert 19 pandemic
there were
been a loss in capital has the
revaluation of capital been taken into
account when deriving the valuation of
equity
[Music]
daniel can you still hear us i think
you're frozen
yeah i can hear you
do you want me to repeat the question
um yes please yeah
[Music]
i was just
wondering whether the revaluation of
capital has been taken into account when
deriving the valuation of equity
maybe i'm sitting too close to the mic
i heard you emily did you get that
so um
i'm not quite sure but i think you were
asking about the
revaluation of the capital
um
do you mean the capital value of the
assets sorry
that's right yeah so as i mentioned
before the um the equity element and the
valuation of that equity
um it is a percentage of the portfolio
value so the overall portfolio value and
so the value the portfolio was revalued
as that 31st of march and so that takes
into account the um the the coveted
lockdown which occurred prior to that
date and so that equity and revaluation
is is a reflection of the portfolio as a
whole so if the equity is 10 percent um
as opposed to
90 debt uh then yes that equity has been
revalued as part of that portfolio
okay
okay thank you
um so we'll now move into debate
very briefly and quickly i hope um so um
who would like to speak first andrew you
still got your hand up is that from
before or after
i mean is that still up would you you
know
okay um harry councillor richardson
[Music]
uh thank you chair i had a few points i
wanted to make but i think just the
interest of brevity i'm going to be uh
i'll condense it down just to say very
quickly that i
would like to thank both councillor
gould and emily for presenting that
report uh which i think was was very
very informative and in particular also
and this is just what i would like to
say is just to thank you
to uh henry christopher and neville
for their contributions because i think
this has probably been the most uh
informative detailed and interesting
discussion we've had about sifco so
thank you to all of their contributions
and if you would be willing to do so i
hope you'll come back and and then
present more information to us as a
council in the future because i think
that really
better informs the decisions that we
make
and i think that's that's really
valuable so thank you very much for that
and
just for the record i will be surprised
we'll be very in favor of this motion
outside this report thank you
thank you um john i see you've got your
camera on do you want to come in you
haven't put your hand up but you know we
want him to speak now
is that me or john whitehead
john whitehead sorry i don't know why
that happened but um yeah well i'll just
like very very briefly just sort of say
that i've worked with some of the civic
non-executives on the gateway 14 project
it's given me an excellent opportunity
to see their knowledge and expertise in
action because all our non-execs are
true veterans of their profession they
each bring a lifetime's worth of
commercial
property evaluation and management
experience to cifco as well as the
lifetime of good contact so i'd like to
have the opportunity to thank them for
their work and also thank emily for all
her own hard work on cifco
and also thank the council of directors
of civico for their oversight and
scrutiny
and
if if it's going to be pushed be
critical in any one way i would just say
to the pacifico board let's widen our
geographical horizons across the uk and
let's get this portfolio completed thank
you
thank you councillor madison
[Music]
thank you chair yes quite quite quickly
um
i'm
sorry that the the really counsellors
and the public are being
rather poorly informed about um
the the business of sifko um i mean
we've certainly gone into it tonight but
i think broadly speaking um poorly
informed because
of the media releases that we put out
which are extremely um
excessively upbeat and therefore
somewhat one-sided and in order to make
decisions
and that's what we're for this has been
said earlier
in order to make decisions we need
balanced information and i'm afraid
that's not what's coming from from our
communications department
now
it's been pointed out and i'm not
surprised at all that we are out
performing the market
and
i'm not surprised by that because
you know i i think our professional team
of
directors and advisors are are very good
i've met probably more of them than many
of you have
um although they are they are
undoubtedly quite expensive as has been
highlighted earlier on
now
what we haven't really
been quite
thorough enough in looking at yet is
what the government are
saying
and the government's the government's um
in fact the permanent secretary of the
ministry of housing community community
local government he said to the public
accounts committee
in relation to the consultation that was
being carried out that councils will be
prevented from investing in commercial
property
and
from accessing the public works loan
board
that we think will stop councils
not only borrowing in particular but
investing in these sorts of commercial
property arrangements that are primarily
for yield that's the
type of civil servant of the ministry
said that's the public accounts
committee of mps
and i'll emphasize and in the middle of
that lot
and
and from accessing stopping
so i think that the
um the government are actually going to
deliver in due course um what the motion
earlier on this evening was see 20
seconds john can we
come there can we
can we therefore please defer approval
of this business plan until we've seen
both the
draft accounts which council williams
referred to but also what the
government's intentions are
after the consultation thank you
thanks i'm so i'm just going to take
councillor ebon councillor mellon
councillor sarah mansell and then we're
going to go to the vote
so councillor eben
[Music]
thank you very much chair um and i just
would like to um
you know i think a lot of the points
have been said um in the debate earlier
this evening um and i would just like to
reiterate that you know i don't have a
problem with any of the advisors
consultants or officers and in fact i've
had many a conversation with with chris
health and henry cook um in the past so
um what i do have a problem with is with
sifko per se um and um
just to
you know point out to some of my fellow
conservative councillors interestingly
it's the conservative councillors in
ipswich that are against what ipswich
are doing so um you know i think it's
you know maybe maybe we should have a
chat with them but um
overall i just don't believe we as a
council should be um
investing in
an arms-length vehicle such as this
and i really
do believe we should actually just be
focusing on on our district and
putting that money into our district um
and and working there and not investing
um in places such as epsom and
southampton so
um as you'll probably all be well aware
i shan't be supporting this um but thank
you to everybody for their
um
comments and their work on it thank you
thanks um counselor melon
thank you chair i will be brief um i
think it's possible to
disagree with the principle of
zifco and put that to one side
um when we start to look at the reality
of its performance
i really don't think we should go away
from here thinking that everything is
going well
or that if things are going badly that
it's all to do with covid
things were going wrong before that rent
arrears were already up in the first
quarter before we locked down
the loans are still largely outstanding
and
the equity has largely gone that's the
headlines we need to take away and on
that basis i can't vote to accept this
report
thank you councillor mansell
thank you
you're very quiet sarah
sorry i i was just a bit alarmed by
something that uh councillor whitehead
uh just said a few moments ago when he
said let's widen our
uh net and and invest across the country
i'm sorry if perhaps i've missed the
point but i'm pretty sure i'd read
somewhere that we still
were meant to be having a bias towards
the eastern region and and the current
split of investments is
is slightly more in the eastern region
and here we have somebody who's openly
saying
we should be widening our our radius and
investing further afield so i'm sorry
that is completely at odds we should be
investing much closer to home
investing in our district and i'm i'm
actually somewhat horrified that
councillor white had made that comment
yeah we're going to go straight to
councillor ghoul to route to round up
well i i i think hang on
right
we we've given this a fairly uh thorough
going over i think which is which is all
to the good uh is a complex matters um
uh and uh
i'm hugely grateful to
our advisers to emily
and the team of advisers for
their contributions this evening in
terms of uh bringing
both clarity and authority
to
to the answers that they gave
so i don't propose to say anything more
at this point other than
um
suggest that we move to the vote now
um um thank you great um so we're going
to move to the recommendation and we're
going to take them um separately as i'm
councillor mansell asked and so the
first recommendation 3.1 the council
notes cifco capital limited trading
activity and performance for the year to
31st of march 2020 i would now ask the
corporate manager for governance and
civic office to take a roll call vote
thank you chair um if members could
reply with or against or abstain
counsellor morrison
[Music]
carter
against councillor
[Music]
or
cancer field
against councillor flatman
for
cancer
[Music]
four that's a humphreys
or councillor mansell against councillor
madison
against councillor mellon
against council mayor
councillor morley
four councillor muller or councillor
norris against councillor otton
against cancer passmore
full
council phillips
against
councillor pratt
councillor richardson
ball
cancer scarf
against councillor stringer
against councillor turner against cancer
war boys against councilwellum against
councillor whitehead four
so that's an equal split and so i will
use my casting vote to carry that and
then we'll make the second
recommendation 3.2 that the council
approves cifco capital
capital limited limited 2020 to 2021
business plan for adoption by sifko
capital limited
and i will now ask the corporate manager
again to of governance and civic office
to take a roll call vote
thank you chair um please can you reply
again with four against or abstain
councillor amorison again
council brewster
four councillor burn
four cancer carter
against council
fleming
[Music]
sorry it's taking a long time to unmute
against
councillor otton against amsterdam
for
councillor phillips
against council pratt
against council richardson four that's
the scarf against that's the stringer
against that's a turner against that's
the war boys
against councillor
against that's the white head
can i interrupt
and
sorry councillor
council field at the field sorry did i
miss you i do
apologize the opposite way to what i
intended
is that my um
you did vote you did vote for would you
like to re-vote
i did intend to vote against i i just
followed the person in front i'm afraid
okay we wouldn't want that thank you
thank you very much
councillor whitehead
uh still four
okay thank you
[Music]
so i'll use my casting vote and then
that will be carried
so that is the um the end of this
meeting the next date of the next
meeting is thursday the 24th of
september at 5 30.
it's been a long night guys and i've got
an hour's drive home
see you all again soon
you